дякую, вітаю всіх, мене звуть
Марія Крістіанчок, я очолюю
науковий проект в Українському
фонді стартапів і буду модератором
сьогоднішнього заходу,
ми готові розпочати наш другий Beach
day
of Science and business to speak
days  дні виступів науки та бізнесу –
це заходи, на яких 40 науковців
та підприємців з готовими
наукомісткими рішеннями
зможуть презентувати свої стартапи, а 24
проекти отримають фінансову підтримку
в розмірі п’яти тисяч доларів
для розвитку своїх інноваційних проектів, які
ми хочемо  щоб висловити нашу вдячність
нашим партнерам, з якими ми організовуємо
заходи в Сирії Міністерству
цифрової трансформації України
Міністерству освіти і науки
України і, звичайно, нашим партнерам, дріжджам
Global Innovations або науці і
технологіям, ми дякуємо всім присутнім
ну звичайно  ми
хочемо висловити величезну подяку
поважним гостям, які приєдналися до нас у
першій групі конкурсного
комітету, який оцінюватиме проект,
і стартапам, які ретельно
підготувалися та готові продемонструвати свої
проекти
минулого тижня проекти в галузі охорони здоров’я та
Категорії «Сільське господарство» та «Біотехнології» представляють свої стартапи, і 10
із них уже отримують фінансову
підтримку від гостей. Приєднуйтесь до нас, щоб переглянути
день першої сторінки на офіційному
каналі Українського фонду стартапів на YouTube, сьогодні ми
матимемо задоволення представити
проект учасників другої групи
енергія та  екологічна та промислова
та інфраструктурна сфери
подія також транслюється на нашому
офіційному YouTube-каналі, тому кожен може
приєднатися до нас у режимі реального часу,
нагадаю про час
стартапи матимуть п’ять хвилин для
виступу, а потім три хвилини
члени конкурсної комісії.
матиме змогу ставити запитання
команді, яку ми
просимо від стартапів відповідати на запитання якомога
конкретніше та послідовніше,
на що зверне увагу журі
є п’ять котячих критеріїв для
оцінювання
перше представлення бізнес-статус
20 облігацій
продукт Відповідність ринку 30 балів наступні кроки
або  дорожня карта 30 балів команда 10 балів і
висновок 10 балів
дозвольте представити, що ви пам'ятаєте, хто
сьогодні буде оцінювати стартапи і вирішувати,
яка команда, хто з них отримає
фінансування
наші основні експерти Наталія
директор дирекції ІТ-індустрії керівник
міського проектного офісу ДС
керівник експертної групи  із
теорії та проектів залучення інвестиційних дій
Керівник освітніх ініціатив I.T
uh
Santa Cruz PhD керівник експертної групи
інноваційного розвитку Управління
наукових інновацій Міністерства
освіти і науки України
Національний координатор витрат Рональд Вайзман
це крісло керівників  в
Angel Capital Association та очолює
Software Industry Group в band of angel
наші сферні експерти Роман Кравіц
керівник департаменту цифрового розвитку та
кібербезпеки Міненерго
України luboff book
партнер-засновник акселератора Blue Lake
та pencil capital
Андрій Вулі керівник аналітики N1
Венчурний експерт USF Ukrainian starter fund
і без жодних слів
давайте підтримаємо першу команду
оплесками,
перша команда буде відновлюватися,
будь ласка, ми вітаємо вас на сцені, привіт
усім, мене звуть Юрій Тустіновський
, я наш генеральний директор Українського
стійкого бренду
відновлення означає переробку обкладинки
каву по-українськи, і ми перетворюємо
використану кавову гущу на
продукти, які можна компостувати з переробленої кавової гущі,
ми розробили наші основні прототипи
одноразові стаканчики стручки розсади
капсули для кавових машин
контейнери для свічок, однак єдиний продукт, який ми
можемо виготовляти в невеликих кількостях на нашому
поточному обладнанні, — це ароматичні свічки в
біорозкладні контейнери з переробленої
кавової гущі
цей продукт уже є в продажу ми
розробили інноваційну технологію, яка
включає такі ключові операції, як
високотехнологічна екстракція змішування пресування та
нанесення природного захисного покриття
наша продукція екологічно
чиста виготовлена ​​з перероблених та
відновлюваних матеріалів
вона відповідає ідеї  Еко-
дизайну
і може бути створений вдома або в
промисловому компості
ми працюємо з кількома кав'ярнями та
офісами в Луїсвіллі Західна Україна тепер
незалежні кав'ярні або великі офіси
виробляють приблизно 100 150 кілограмів
кавових відходів щомісяця ми збираємо використану
кавову гущу для подальшої переробки
і в той же час допомогти їм заощадити
витрати на утилізацію відходів.
Мільйони вироблених контейнерів для свічок
зі склобетону або пластику з
металевими слабкими тримачами взагалі не піддаються біологічному розкладанню.
Ці цифри показують, що ми
близькі до екологічної катастрофи, і
настав час взяти їх під контроль.
проблеми
кришки свічок Інноваційні свічки
в контейнерах із переробленої кавової
гущі,
наповнені найякіснішими
ароматними грунтами та барвниками преміум-класу, коли
свічка догорає, її унікальний контейнер
можна утилізувати, відсортувавши для
компостування органічних фракцій, або
використовувати як біологічно розкладаний  горщик для розсади на
тижневий тримач ми використовуємо вогнестійку
біокораміку на основі яєчної шкаралупи
це наша власна ідея та
альтернатива металевим слабким тримачам, які
зазвичай використовують виробники свічок
перша колекція свічок rukawa
присвячена символічним ароматам
українських міст та регіонів вона вже
містить  11 різних свічок,
наприклад KU з ароматом бузку та
каштана або її син був Ромою ветераном
до повномасштабного російського вторгнення
пілоти відновили виробництво було розташоване в
літній північно-східній Україні, коли
лабораторія опинилася в
зоні бойових дій Команди з відновлення вирішили
переїхати в безпечніше місце з 22 квітня
Recover працює в Луїсвіллі, Західна
Україна, наразі ми продаємо рекупераційні
свічки в помірних кількостях у нашому
інтернет-магазині в соціальних мережах і B2B, нам потрібне
відповідне обладнання для повномасштабного
виробництва,
для нас також було великою честю виграти
це вибори серед стартапів і брендів,
які вони збиралися представляти
Україну на виставці CES 23 цього січня, це
щорічна
виставка, організована Асоціацією споживчих технологій
у Лас-Вегасі, одна з
найвпливовіших технічних подій у світі, про яку
ми отримали розголос, про що писали провідні іноземні
ЗМІ  ми також
розширили наш бізнес і
розпочали переговори з потенційними
партнерами та покупцями B2B.
Зараз це маленький український бізнес, але це
була велика соціальна місія, про яку ми мріяли
врятувати планету від одноразового пластику
та інших нерозкладних відходів за
допомогою  наших екологічно чистих
продуктів і просування циклічної економіки як
основної глобальної економічної моделі,
давайте працювати разом над більш
стійким майбутнім. Дякуємо,
дякуємо за вашу презентацію, а тепер
ми просимо відбірковий комітет поставити
свої запитання, будь ласка,
так, гм, міс, привіт
усім, дякую  для вашої
презентації, і в мене є два запитання,
починаючи з першого запитання, наскільки
клієнти бажають ваш продукт за
певний період і як щодо планів щодо
майбутнього розвитку цього стартапу, чи
можете ви повторити перше запитання
про те, як ви оцінюєте бажання клієнтів
щодо вашого продукту  наразі
та про ваші плани на майбутнє, дякую,
гм, оскільки сьогодні ми намагаємося допомогти
спілкуватися з нашими клієнтами та нашими
підписниками, наприклад, у соціальних мережах
Сторінки у нас є наша пошукова власна невелика
спільнота,
перш за все, це люди, яких турбують
екологічні проблеми та  проблеми, які ми маємо,
наприклад,
створення нового продукту, як-от нова
свічка з такого особливого регіону чи міста,
з правом спілкуватися з місцевими жителями
та
знайти в деяких історичних чи також
матеріалах такі справжні символічні аромати,
тому що мова йде не лише
про свічки, це  також про символ
повернення додому, і тому ми
намагаємося не тільки зробити щось, ми
бачимо, як ми побачимо цей продукт, ми
також намагаємося залучити нашу спільноту і,
звичайно, на сьогоднішній день для наших
глобальних планів, які ви можете побачити тут  але
для нас дуже важливо
отримати нове обладнання,
тому що це допомагає нам виробляти нашу
продукцію в більшій кількості і
не тільки відновлювати свічки, але також
відновлювальні чашки та інше, тому цього
року ми хотіли б залучити
інвестиції в цю сферу,
дякую  ви
добре, дякую,
шановні експерти, у нас є час на ще одне
запитання,
якщо немає запитань, дякуємо
за ваш виступ і давайте запросимо наступного
учасника, е-переробка електронних відходів,
ми бачимо вашу презентацію, але,
на жаль, у центрі е-е,
добре е-
е  доброго дня мене звуть
я представляю вам бізнес-проект
електронна база з низьким вмістом
прецизійних металів
добре проект вирішує проблему
зростання екологічного ризику та
повернення до промислового виробництва на придатній
для носіння сировині ми можемо виграти
над чим ми працюємо  ці проекти
протягом п’ятого року і мають великий
досвід і спеціальні знання в
цій галузі
електронні відходи є великою проблемою,
тому що вони завжди з найвищим
валовим рівнем у світі містять
небезпечні компоненти та несуть ризик
для екологічного середовища
згідно зі світовою статистикою
Автономність електронних відходів становить 50
мільйонів тонн на рік, і лише 17
відсотків електронних відходів утворюється
із загального обсягу електронного
брухту, до 70 відсотків може стати нашою
сировиною, наприклад, екранні монітори,
комп’ютерна техніка та багато іншого,
тепер ви можете представити  механічне
гравітаційне повідомлення або обробка, яку
мені доведеться перетворити як були початкові
хвилі або шляхи в доступні продукти
це наша сировина в основному
електронні плати його матеріали, які ми
автоматично вирішуємо це прецизійний
концентрат Купер концентрат алюмінієві
кораблі та чорні метали
наш
наша продукція має середню ціну
шість тисяч доларів за одну тонну, але може
зрости залежно від кількості
електронних відходів наша власна діяльність
сприяла тому, щоб ми протистояли цьому
процесу, продовживши 500 тонн
електронних відходів накопичить 250
тонн відходів від нашої власної обробки
та  тепер ми хочемо запровадити процес
перепродажу 100 способів перетворити на
корисні продукти, і наш ланцюжок вторинної переробки новин
включатиме безкоштовний етап, перший
механічний гравітаційний метод, другий
термальний метод, а останній етап – це
електрогідравліка.
Реалізація кожного етапу, яку ви можете
запитати ближче до  більша ефективність і
повний нуль відходів,
тепер ви можете побачити частину нашого вхідного
обладнання в нашій галузі.
Наш проект є діючим підприємством,
розташованим у регіоні Кім поблизу
міста Бродвей, і має 1,5 гектара відкритого
робочого місця та 500 квадратних метрів
промислових будівель, які ми маємо  мережа
постачальників доступні платоспроможні клієнти
ми не були на наркотиках інвестиції у
вісімсот тисяч доларів
впровадження циклу переробленої їжі
при залученні інвестицій збільшення
доходу до 3,8 мільйона доларів на
рік – це точно
також у нас є бачення Ціль
досягнення цього  привабливі інвестиції за
три роки, по-перше, перевести наш бізнес
у високотехнологічне підприємство,
по-друге, пілотувати нову бізнес-модель і
розширити мережу подібних
регіональних підприємств, по-третє, побудувати
міжнародну мережу поставок сировини,
наприклад, на міжнародному рівні
в минулому році ми взяли участь в
Українській державній  програму для
підприємств, що розвиваються або переробляють,
і отримати грант у розмірі 7,7
мільйонів глядачів від Міністерства економіки
України, а також у рамках
програми інвестиційного кільця до лютого 2023 року
вище наших конкурентів, де перша
і єдина компанія з утилізації електронних відходів
в Україні  найближчі
конкуренти розташовані в Західній
Європі, але вони жодним чином не впливають на наш
сировинний ринок про нашу
групу директорів це сімейний бізнес
сергій мій батько це
менеджер з інновацій моя мати мила учениця це
фінанси та бухгалтерія моя сестра
міжнародний менеджер  і це дуже
гарний красивий розумний хлопець це я про
управління виробництвом і операціями
про висновок що у вас є
необмежений ринок чи сировина другі
постійні клієнти певні можливі
сканування нашої компанії була
можливість відкрити більше з 10 таких
виробничих потужностей в Україні та
за кордоном наш бізнес уже є
робочим проектом з перепродажу електронних
шляхів та
унікальних засобів для здоров'я технологічного середовища, і остання
компанія вже була перевірена
міністерством економіки України, дякую за
увагу, наш вміст
інформація готова для вашого навчання,
дякую за вашу презентацію та е-е
ми запрошуємо наших шановних не забути
ставити свої запитання
[Музика],
шановний учасник Junior, буде вдячний,
якщо ви задасте запитання,
отже, якщо все зрозуміло, дякуємо за
вашу презентацію, і ми запрошуємо наступного
учасника optisan
слово вам
[Музика]
дуже скоро  добре, ви бачите мій екран, так,
з тих пір, добре, дякую,
добре, супер, дозвольте мені почати, привіт усім, мене
звуть
технологія очищення та
дезінфекції води за будь-яких умов
про воду Все населення світу
страждає від нестачі питної води
близько півмільйона столів проходить повз
щорічно, і всі ці проблеми
сильно посилюються поганою логістикою та
інфраструктурою, що
забезпечує надмірне вживання алкоголю, що є однією
з найбільш глобальних проблем у світі,
і особливі ніші, які займають люди,
які живуть у зоні постійних
надзвичайних ситуацій і проблем, і ось
Кілька прикладів, як-от шторми, торнадо,
повені, які я зазвичай висвітлюю в місцях проживання
в Україні, наприклад, проблема є надзвичайно
важливою, у нас є всі військові у
приблизно 30 відсотках внутрішньо переміщених
осіб, які сильно потребують
питної води,
а
організації витрачають десятки грошей на
постачання  вони з ним
наше рішення проблеми полягає в
тому, що триступеневий пристрій для очищення та
дезінфекції chisan фільтр сирої води
озонування та очищення Ultra Ballard
дозволили знищити 99 відсутність бактерій
автономно та без будь-яких витратних матеріалів
після доставки він може працювати протягом
тривалого періоду часу
все  вам потрібно наповнити його
брудною водою, поставити на сонце або підключити
до іншого джерела електроенергії та
натиснути цю кнопку через 30 хвилин, у вас є
дев’ять літрів питної води, готової до
використання.
-урядові
організації, які займаються забезпеченням
питною водою серійних військових і всіх людей, які перебувають у надзвичайних ситуаціях,
і наша бізнес-модель базується на
отриманні контрактів з двома або більше
сотнями продавців пристроїв на
рік і технічне обслуговування один раз на два
роки,
як  Наступний наш етап — це досягнення
сегментів b2c через продавців.
Ціннісна пропозиція дуже проста.
Високопродуктивні витратні матеріали
та низькі витрати на воду призводять до повної
автономності в надзвичайних ситуаціях.
Ми досягаємо витрат на
обладнання, непромислове обладнання,
витрати на величезний ринок очищення води
та наш  сума базується на
перевіреному сегменті споживачів
водопостачання в Україні та США, у нашому плані на
перший рік продажі досягають одного
відсотка, з якого Health Market
наша фінансова модель також побудована для
тієї ж мети, і вона містить 10
контрактів, які дозволять  нам досягти
одного відсотка плацдарму Продуктивність ринку
відсутність регулярних витрат
або
на транспортування та високий
ресурс є нашими головними перевагами серед
конкурентоспроможних технологій і
наведемо приклад у випадку логістичних
платежів приблизно на 400 кілометрів у
разі постачання людей питвом
водою можна було б забезпечити
питною водою в 10 разів більше людей
за ту саму суму грошей,
тому на поточному етапі ми маємо лабораторний
прототип і технологію, у нас є три
зразки, у нас є демонстраційний стенд, ми
брали участь на арені, каже, що у
2022 році ми маємо  чотири
попередні угоди про продаж B2B, і ми досягли
заяви про розбірливість у Фінляндії для
стартапів, ми
вже досягли 50 KF
Інвестиції, які нам потрібні від онука,
наші власні гроші, і ми все ще шукаємо
на поточному етапі додаткових 50 тисяч
для завершення нашої промислової групи крові
та  процес сертифікації зробити його першим
серйозним виходом на ринок і здійснити ваші
перші продажі та підвищити
оцінку нашої компанії до одного
мільйона доларів
ми домовилися з більш ніж 50
організаціями, які допомагають людям
щодня ми вже маємо чотири
угоди про продаж як контракти ми  маємо
інтелектуальну власність, у нас є наукові
та сертифікаційні університети-партнери,
і у нас є кілька ділових партнерів,
засновники optisam є докторами
наук з електроніки та докторами наук у галузі
біомедичної електроніки, і ми маємо великий
досвід розробки апаратного забезпечення, і як
команда ми працюємо разом більше
п’яти років  і це дозволяє нам відчувати себе вільними в
усьому, що ми робимо разом,
тому наш поточний етап полягає в пошуку
партнерів для інвестицій у виробництво та
спеціалістів із захисту інтелектуальної власності для
консультантів.
Дякую за увагу, і я готовий до
запитань.
учасники до місця
для запитання та відповіді
[Музика]
Я коли-небудь бачив, як
ясно тут або будь-хто хоче
запитати його все зрозуміло чудовий
проект, тож дякую за ваш виступ дякую
сподіваюсь це чудовий знак
дякую Оксано  а тепер ух
ми так ми запрошуємо наступний проект ух
hand free
the floor is your
please [
Музика]
привіт усім мене звуть Саша Масенко
я капітан проекту hands-free Я
студент технологічно-промислового
професійно-технічного коледжу ім.  Міжнародний
аграрний університет Золотий
проект Power hands-free це літаючий пристрій на
відстані на висоті, який розміщує в
будинку, наприклад, полиці, шафи тощо,
щоб зберегти
чистоту від сюрпризів в автоматичному та
напівавтоматичному настрої, багато
людей не можуть  робити прибирання,
наприклад, інші люди, бізнес-леді,
алергія, вагітні жінки, але є
також позитивний момент, що
діти можуть бути залучені до цього
прогресу, і вони навіть хочуть допомогти
своїм батькам прибрати, що є
вихід за допомогою рук або  послуга клінінгової компанії,
але це не дуже вигідне
рішення, зроблене без рук для дистанційного
перегляду важкодоступних місць,
функціональні можливості, спочатку кожне
відео руху, потім автоматичне керування,
що воно автоматично, напівавтоматичний
режим і останнє, побудова
групи карт
Ринок  по-перше, наша мета -
виготовити пристрій, потім Outlet
Ukraine і остання перспективна робота для
конкурентів на ринку доступність це так, як ви
можете вмикати його коли завгодно правильно
ви можете заплатити лише один раз на захист ви можете
створити свій тайм-менеджмент і людський
фактор там  чи ніхто інший не
втручається в прибирання
мета розвитку проекту
лише 60 відсотків маркетинг це 15 і
адміністрація 25.
шлях розробки та виробництва
експериментального зразка без рук
перша ідея створити що завгодно потім
розробка маркетингове дослідження потім
пошук інвестора  і
впровадження, а
також я хочу представити
відео
чудовий дім, про який ви завжди
мріяли, зробили все, щоб було
комфортно вам і вашим гостям, ви
все зробили правильно, але чи впевнені ви,
що блискуча поверхня буде запорукою
чистоти вашого дому?  Здавалося б,
навіщо нам генеральне прибирання,
якщо ми прибираємо будинок щотижня. Правда,
є важкодоступні місця з
великим шаром пилу, на які ми не звертаємо
уваги. Дослідження німецьких
вчених підтвердили, що на один
квадратний метр підлоги в  житлова кімната
покриває близько семи міліграмів пилу
на рік ця кількість становить цілих 3
грами ці показники особливо
високі в старих будівлях, звідки
надходить пил приблизно 70% побутового
пилу має природне походження, решта
тридцять відсотків пилу є  виробляється
самими людьми, ви можете запитати, яка
небезпека в цьому, ми відповідаємо,
накопичення пилу та бруду створює
сприятливі умови для
розмноження бактерій, які призводять до
різних захворювань, але є
безкоштовне рішення проблеми - це літаючий
пристрій для віддаленого  прибирання
важкодоступних місць будинку призначений для
підтримки чистоти поверхонь і автоматичний в
напівосінньому режимі Матик за структурою
складається з двох частин перша основна,
яка включає механізм для
переміщення в просторі і механізм для
прибирання друга  дочірнє підприємство,
яке є базою для заряджання та
обслуговування механізм для пересування
в просторі складається з чотирьох гвинтів блок живлення система
автоматичного керування
GPS модуль барометр датчики для
виявлення перешкод відеокамера та
блок управління очисний механізм
включає поверхневий очисник  і
автоматична система очищення інфрачервоні та
повні датчики контактні безконтактні
датчики датчики перешкод лазерний
далекомір обидва механізми
управляються в пристрої за допомогою спеціального
програмного забезпечення, яке дозволяє робити це
дистанційно через смартфон або ПК в
автоматичному або напівавтоматичному режимі
так як для моніторингу роботи
пристрою в онлайн-режимі пристрій використовує
лазерну навігацію, яка забезпечує
можливість створення карти
приміщення, спеціальні лазерні далекоміри фіксують
відстань до стін, меблів і
зберігають дані в пам'яті пристрою,
допомагаючи будувати специфікації ран акумулятора
пристрій виглядає як
плоский циркуляційний насос діаметр
пристрою може варіюватися від 15 до 35
сантиметрів висота пристрою
від 15 до 25 сантиметрів вага
коливається від одного до двох кілограм
тривалість роботи до двох ом
робот-пилосос оснащений
різними типами щіток є
зовнішні датчики для сканування простору
обминаючи перешкоди для оптимального маршруту пересування
тип орієнтування в
просторі лазерна навігація яка передбачає
можливість побудови карти
приміщення є  відеокамера, яка
встановлена ​​у верхній найвищій точці
панелі та сканує інформацію зі
стін, підлоги, стелі та меблів, такий
пристрій рухається по прямих лініях і
поперемінно переміщується з кімнати в кімнату. Наш
пристрій щось нагадує,
звичайно, поєднання звичайного
пилосос і дрон - це
рішення, на яке чекають усі, хто хоче мати
чисті домівки,
дякую за презентацію, а тепер,
шановний, пам'ятайте, слово за вами,
якщо у вас виникли запитання
щодо проекту
[Музика]
так, дякую за ваш  презентація,
оскільки все зрозуміло, ми
вітаємо наступну команду,
так,
дякую за вашу презентацію, у мене є
запитання,
на ринку є дуже багато аналогів, думаю, ви
знаєте про це, і, можливо, ви можете
виділіть ключові переваги ваших
пристроїв, тому що я вважаю, що
важливо знати,
які відмінності та чому клієнти
повинні вибрати ваш пристрій,
хм, ми беремо цю вечірку закоханих за основу,
а потім нам потрібно розробити верхню
частину та представити її
емм цей пристрій краще  ніж у магазині,
тому що
цей пристрій має крила, і він може літати на
столі чи шафах і
чистити все, що завгодно, і
ви також можете підключити його до свого телефону
та дивитися на цьому, як він прибирає, а
також ні, у нього є такі вбудовані датчики  оскільки
він може орієнтуватися в просторі та розуміти,
коли він досяг продажу або
кінця столу,
і
це розумніший пристрій, ніж у
базовому на той час безпілотнику,
або я думаю, що все
гаразд, дякую, дякую
за ваше запитання та дякую
за вашу презентацію  ми вітаємо на
підлозі наступну команду solar plex
сонячні вилки над цими
добре дякую так ми чуємо вас
добре ми використовуємо для планів скорочення
викидів CO2, але все ще отримуємо енергію
ККД звичайної старої фотоелектричної панелі становить
близько 20 відсотків, і це нормально
найбільшою проблемою будь-якої фотоелектричної панелі є наше
опалення. 25 відсотків енергії втрачається,
але нам, людям, потрібна теплова енергія, щоб
нагріти воду, наприклад, і ми використовуємо екологічну
електроенергію для цієї мети, що
не має сенсу, крім того, ми недоотримуємо вісім
тисяч доларів на рік на середній
будинок, щоб  нагрівати воду сонцем, і ми
не маємо достатньо місця за нашими правилами, щоб
використовувати обидва типи панелей для отримання
теплової та електричної енергії
від сонячного сплетення, наша команда пропонує спосіб
зменшити викиди CO2, щоб мати
енергонезалежність у кожному будинку та
державну енергію  постачальником,
водночас ми ознайомилися з технологією
виготовлення гібридних фотоелектричних панелей із будь-якої фотоелектричної панелі.
Наші партнери — монтажники сонячних установок
і будівельні компанії, які пропонують
продукцію нашим клієнтам
Arabic Head Market — це домашні сонячні
установки на даху будівельний ринок
зростає  з кожним роком, і кількість
встановлених домашніх сонячних електростанцій
також зростає з кожним роком завдяки урядовому
стимулюванню використання екологічно чистої енергії,
наша ціннісна пропозиція кристально зрозуміла:
клієнт отримує енергію, вироблену власними силами,
за фіксованою ціною вдвічі дешевшою, ніж
поточний постачальник, ви пам’ятаєте  у
скільки разів вартість енергії зросла чи
зменшилася. Я не пам’ятаю, яка ціна на енергію. Зниження.
Клієнт отримує гарячу воду та
підігрів басейну лише за допомогою нашого продукту, якщо ми
додаємо повітряний тепловий насос, ми отримуємо опалення, або
за допомогою ґрунтового теплового насоса ми можемо
ми пропонуємо ці переваги простим способом, ми
додаємо систему рідинного охолодження в
полімерному корпусі зі спеціальною конфігурацією
до фотоелектричної панелі Canon, в результаті чого ми отримуємо
гібридну панель, яка
виробляє як електричні, так і теплові
Енергія
середнього будинку виробляє 26 тонн CO2
щороку завдяки сонячному сплетінню
це число зменшиться у п’ять з половиною разів.
Наша команда Хелен Бахірова відповідає
за науку та технології, вона є
автором восьми шаблонів із більш ніж
20-річним досвідом і  сонячна енергія
лексикограф відповідає за
управління Автоматизація та
інженерія він має шість років
досвіду в сонячній енергетиці Alexa
спостережений відповідає за
розвиток бізнесу та комунікації він має
більше ніж 10 років досвіду, а я
і метролов є директором сонячного сплетення
або досягнень, які ми вже досягли  участь у
виставці CES 2023, коли undp GC IP і взяли участь
у програмі прискорення екологічних бойових дій,
дозвольте мені сказати кілька слів про наші
наступні кроки цього року, ми плануємо
побудувати кілька збірок в Україні, також ми
відчуваємо, що завершуємо роботу щодо
захисту AP на міжнародному ринку  і
шукаєте інвесторів для початку або
розширення в Європі Європейський Союз або
Сполучені Штати Америки,
давайте виженемо Росію з вашого ринку зараз
за допомогою сонячного сплетення, дякую за вашу
увагу,
презентація, а тепер час для
запитань
[Музика]
шановні члени журі,
добре,
пане  Зубні протези, дякуємо за вашу
презентацію та за ваш час, ми
вітаємо на сцені наступну команду Max act
LLC, ах, Алекс LC
Так, так, дякую вам за сцену, дорогі
учасники, вони журі, дозвольте мені
розповісти вам про майбутнє, воно
точно станеться, якщо  ви хочете внести свій внесок
у зміну цього у 2022 році
лише в Європі, у нас є 295
000 тонн відео мої власні відходи акумуляторів
у 2030 році Європейська комісія з
електрифікації згадує, що їх буде в
шість разів більше, чи не таке відчуття, що
наступна катастрофа пластикових відходів дайте відповідь
самі  ми, українська наукова та
бізнес-команда, засвоїли уроки
минулого та зробили свій внесок у його уникнення. Maxa — це
оператор технології прямого відновлення, який
буквально розвиває виробництво екологічно чистих акумуляторних
матеріалів, роблячи їхнє
виробництво на 50 швидшим, на 40 дешевшим і на 70
відсотків екологічнішим.
лише 42
фабрики рекуперації в Європі
згідно з нашим складним процесом адаптації до ринку
та перевірки стратегії ми
з’ясовуємо кілька численних проблем
із технологією, виправляємо її високу
вартість рекуперації, це величезне споживання енергії,
це трудомісткий процес, який
обмежений у продуктивності, а також для
всього  Завод щорічно та високий
незадоволений попит, тож насправді існує
більше способів, ніж ці заводи можуть
визначити вуглецевий слід витрати фільтр
синтаксичний тиск кожен гріх вимагає
витрат і робить цей бізнес, який нам
справді потрібен неефективним
Макс рішення дозволяє ракетно запускати
процеси з 70 менше вуглецю
площа на 40 відсотків менше виробничих
витрат, що дозволяє отримувати більше
прибутку, і те, що заважає, немає потреби в
реструктуризації виробничих ділянок,
це все залежить від інженерів Maxa, щоб адаптувати
існуючі машини та процеси,
давайте подивимося на технологію Maxa розробляє
власну унікальну версію
технології прямого відновлення, яка  займає чотири
чотири кроки замість 10. У
звичайних піро- та
гідрометалургійних процесах це
застосовне для різних типів літій-іонів,
які використовуються для електротранспорту,
вітрової та сонячної енергії, споживчої
електроніки та багато іншого.
тому що наше пряме відновлення
колосальне, зараз воно зростає приблизно на шість
тридцять відсотків у складних річних
темпах зростання до того часу, ми плануємо
обслуговувати до 2030 року так, ми плануємо
обслуговувати 710 тонн для Max Recovery
Technologies тисячі, тож насправді ми
можемо зрозуміти всю проблему в
собі  з наявними та будуючими
заводами лише одна технологія
так, е-е, конкуренція за вас, Макс,
позиція на ринку порушується
таким чином, що всі навколо прагнуть
створити кінцевий продукт, який потребує набагато
більше коштів і часу, тоді як ми використовуємо існуючу
інфраструктуру заводів для його виготовлення  наполовину
ефективніший Swedish Norse World U.S.
Princeton New Energy Німецький до нуля
вони на ринку набагато довше, ніж
ми, але вони залишаються без доходу, тому що
потрібен час, щоб виробити кінцевий продукт, який
ми досягли протягом одного року з
дати реєстрації 95 відновлення
якість пілотує нашу технологію з корейською
Samsung згідно з NDA та досягає рівня trl5
з ними наша наукова команда належить до
непро електрохімічного Національного інституту
та Національної академії наук
електрохімії спектр у 2022 році ми стали
кліматом запущено Глобальний конкурс
Півфіналісти в майбутніх семи років
перспективі I  Вибачте, ми хочемо
піти, ми не залишимо лише
процеси переробки, ми вже розробили літієві
сульфобатареї та графенові батареї.
Технології паралельно, тож це для
майбутнього розвитку, давайте подивимося на
бізнес-модель, це не продукт, а
ліцензія на виробництво, у нас є  попит
і п’ять відсотків у п’ять разів менше.
Пропозиція, настав час зрозуміти, що
тільки 500 на тонну переробленого
матеріалу буде генерувати 30 мільйонів
доходу до 2030 року.
вони можуть інвестиції, тому п’ять
мільйонів інвестицій на 15 діляться, щоб зробити
пряме відновлення
доступна комерціалізація технологій, тому основна
структура витрат – це лабораторія, тому що
це величезні електрохімічні процедури,
і насправді, якщо наш інвестор є
професіоналом галузі, як ми зараз
обговорюємо, наприклад, із Samsung, так,
вони можуть надати цю лабораторію
безкоштовно, тож наші інвестиції становитимуть лише
1,5  мільйон і скільки зусиль від цього
Основні етапи розвитку – це зараз
збір грошей
захист прав інтелектуальної власності розвиток лабораторії
технологія, а потім ми йдемо на
ринок
продажів так, наша команда, як я вже згадував, ми
бізнесмен і науковці в тандемі,
ну я, генеральний директор і  CDO є докторами наук, тож ми насправді
розуміємо, що таке селекторна хімія, а
всі інші — з
індустрії акумуляторів, і наша наукова команда, яку я люблю
найбільше, тож хлопці — доктори й доктори наук із
електрохімії, це їхнє життя, тому вони
знають, що вони насправді роблять, тому ми
сильні хлопці в  на цьому я завершую
свої презентації, це була єдина
фраза, експертність, швидкість є результатом
вашого лідера на ринку, тож
візьміть нас,
дякую, дякую за
вашу презентацію, шановні
ваші члени, у
вас є запитання, просто напишіть, о,
я  дуже радий, якщо ви запитали мене про
партнерство. Я буду дуже радий, якщо ви
запитали мене про фактичний вуглецевий слід,
скільки одна тонна батарей становить
перероблений матеріал, що зменшує викиди CO2, це
колосально, просто запитайте мене,
сукана, будь
ласка, дайте відповідь на своє запитання, переконайтеся, що
ваша робота стартова площадка так, ну  хлопці
насправді надали нам величезну послугу
Європейської комісії з впливу на клімат, щоб
обчислити фактичний параметр скорочення викидів CO2
однією тонною цього матеріалу, тож
подивіться, 95 тонн CO2 можна зменшити за допомогою
однієї тонни переробленого матеріалу чому, тому що
насправді це величезна дорога, перш ніж
вона буде  це видобуток корисних копалин, це багато головоломок,
палива, це багато процедур, це
транспортування, це логістика, це
божевільно, так, це 66 000
слонів,
уявіть собі, 66 000 розробок, це
багато, так,
дякую, і в мене є ще одне запитання, не
могли б ви описати в  деталі
про вашу
інфраструктуру та мою потужність обладнання
вашого проекту, що ви маєте на даний момент
і що вам потрібно на майбутнє для розвитку
вашого проекту,
так, як я вже згадував, це
глибоко технічний, це науковий проект, тому
це суто апаратне забезпечення, тому у нас є наш
друзі в нашому глибшому електрохімічному
університеті та Національній академії
наук України, отже, це
галузь електрохімії,
я впевнений, що ви краще за мене знаєте
ситуацію з наукою в
Україні та як виглядають їхні лабораторії,
тому що я фактично бачу
щотижня так  тому це не спосіб
розвинути цей проект так швидко, як ми хочемо,
і ми можемо, щоб наші вчені могли з
цією лабораторією, тому нам фактично потрібно
перевезти команду до повноцінної абсолютно
нової лабораторії, і знадобиться
лише рік, щоб представити таку  таку
технологію та вирішити проблему, тож
Samsung тепер начебто у них є щось у
Європі, так, і в Ізраїлі, тож ми
зараз обговорюємо це, щоб перейти через
наукову групу до цієї лабораторії, так,
тому що насправді це дуже дорого,
і ми не можемо, це як виграш  ці 3,5
мільйона з магазину, ось як
зараз показує наша стратегія перевірки інвестицій, тому ми пішли на пілот із
Samsung,
я думаю, ви можете після сьогоднішніх Peach Days надіслати
текст нашому міністерству спеціально для мене,
і я
допоможу вам із цією проблемою, оскільки  ми
знаємо можливості
знайти деяке обладнання, тож, можливо, воно буде
корисним для вас, це точно буде,
безумовно, тому що воно коштує багато і
фактично відкладає розвиток
для всієї Європи та всього
світу, дякую, дякую,
дякую за  ваше запитання та за те, що ви
ділитеся такими дивовижними можливостями та
можливостями з нашими стартапами, і я
бачу, що обидві книги також надійшли до
рук, будь ласка, поділіться сюди, так,
дуже дякую, е-е, Алексіс, дякую за
вашу презентацію, е-е, мені особисто
важко слідкувати за  будьте
з вами абсолютно чесними, я
ціную, що попереду багато роботи та
науки, і так, багато
зусиль, але не могли б ви пояснити таким
повільним людям, як я, що насправді
ви створюєте, тож що це за
продукт,
добре, тож давайте  перейдіть до цього резервного
слайда, підготовленого саме для цього запитання, тож
подивіться, у нас є фабрика, а на
фабриці у нас є обладнання, це обладнання
працює завдяки людям і завдяки
технології, тож це технологічний цикл,
який проходить як один раз після того, як ми сказали, що
не вчасно, тому  ми тут використовуємо звичайний
технологічний цикл, який просто залишає
поза усвідомленням, тож це
процес, щоб виробити тонну
рекупераційного матеріалу для виробництва
батареї, нам потрібно піти на 10-етапний
процес,
він викидає багато CO2, це коштує  багато
часу це генерує низький прибуток, так, у
Max ми розробляємо цей технічний цикл,
щоб зробити їх набагато ефективнішими,
заробляти більше грошей
і викидати менше CO2,
це те, що ми робимо, ми розробляємо
технології для існуючих заводів для
відновлення літій-іонних батарей
ліцензійна технологія,
дякую, чи це
відповідає вашому
питанню, так, так,
майте на увазі, тоді це
відгук не обов’язково лише для вас,
але, мабуть, для всіх майте на
увазі, що потенційні інвестори можуть
не бути  я знайомий із галуззю, тому я
рекомендую всім присутнім у
цій кімнаті залишатися простими,
так, просто використовуйте зрозумілу мову, щоб описати
те, що ви створюєте,
і будьте упереджені до
простоти, якщо я можу це відчувати,
тому що це завжди допомагає  дуже
дякую, так, так, не тільки
емоції, але це прості слова, я
ціную ваші коментарі,
дякую, дякую за запитання,
і у нас є ще одне запитання від
представника Міністерства енергетики
України, Роман Кравіц, залиште
слово,
дякую  я дуже люблю батареї,
тому я поставив кілька запитань, чи ви
зосереджені лише на хімії літій-іонних
батарей, чи ви
розглядаєте інші способи, які ми маємо
зараз, наприклад теорема літію, фосфат,
чи, можливо, майбутнє титану, це
ніби ви знаєте далі  чи
плануєте ви прийти в цю
сферу,
так, будь ласка, і друге
невелике запитання полягало б у тому, що після
переробки батареї, я не
дуже зрозумів, що перероблений
матеріал знову буде використовуватися в батареях
і що, що  чи вплине це якось на
ємність акумуляторів,
виготовлених із цього матеріалу,
чи ні,
це чудове питання, давайте
тепер поговоримо про хімію, тож у нас є
весь спектр літій-іонних акумуляторів,
вони можуть бути літій-марганцевими літій-
феронфосфатними або залізними  фосфат,
так, бачите титан, як ви згадали,
так, усі ці літій-іонні батареї
генерують таку кількість лише
в Європі, так, уся ця
енергія Force Multiple, тому наша технологія
застосовна для кожної батареї
lfp, літій, оксид марганцю, так, літій,
титан, тому кожна  і все, але лише
залишаю вам свої власні, щоб ви не знали, не
вихідні батареї, які ми використовуємо в простих
приватних транспортних засобах, тому ми не збираємося цього
робити, тому що їх кількість набагато
нижча, тому немає жодних причин, так, гм,
ваше друге запитання, е-е, щодо  до
технології та якості відновлення,
тож так, ми підемо туди, так, ну,
як виглядає акумулятор, наче це
металевий лист із чорним порошком на ньому, тож
це має 100 ємностей, а потім зменшується
до нуля або до шістдесяти відсотків, і ми
чи можемо ми його відновити, тож ми зараз
відновлюємо 95 відсотків якості, але,
звичайно, технологія буде комерціалізована
з відновленням 100, тож питання номер один, так,
це буде сто відсотків
попередніх, як, як, повністю, як ранні
матеріали, тому, як первинні матеріали,
однакові, але  відновлений матеріал, що стосується
більш розширених характеристик, як ви
можете бачити, так, ми розробили графенові
графенові батареї, тому графен – це
те, що насправді може зробити
літій-іонні батареї, особливо з
більшою ємністю, це,
звичайно, майбутні розробки, але так, так, ми
думаємо про додатковий  продукт, коли
галузь зараз галузь дуже молода, тому
достатньо віддати 100 відновлених
продуктів у два рази дешевше, ніж ви
купите їх на ранньому майнінгу,
так, але тоді, коли галузь
виросте, і ми підростемо до того часу,
і матимемо  дохід, який потрібно реінвестувати в наш
розвиток, безсумнівно, зробить наш
матеріал, але з більш розширеними
характеристиками, тому що літієва сірка,
яка, ну, розуміється як майбутнє
акумуляторів, є чимось дуже складним, тому це
може статися, воно з’явиться в 2003 році, це
може статися не тому, що так,
це  безперечно так, тому що деякі
експерти вважають, що ідея
титанових батарей у будь-якому випадку
має свій власний спосіб
реалізації, наприклад, літій-
титанові батареї є найкращими, якщо
вам потрібна мала ємність, але дуже висока
потужність, яка вам потрібна.  тож
це дуже цікавий момент, я радий,
що ви, ну, хтось в Україні
займається проблемами
акумуляторів, і, чесно кажучи, оскільки ми
бачимо поточну ситуацію, кількість
акумуляторів зростатиме, зростатиме, і
проблема має бути вирішена Мені це подобається
абсолютно абсолютно дякую Романе Я
ціную ваше розуміння та те, як
ви знаєте, це було справді
приємно мені та українській
електрохімії, звичайно, дякую, дякую,
велике спасибі за ваші
запитання, а тепер ми  готовий
вітати наступного учасника,
будь ласка, слово за
вами, привіт усім,
усі бачать мою презентацію, так,
з тих пір добре, добре, привіт, мене
звати Ендрю, я засновник Melt Water
Club і я  Я радий бути сьогодні тут. У мене
є запитання до кожного з вас, чи
пили ви сьогодні воду, що, якби я сказав вам,
що понад 920 мільйонів дітей у всій
групі щодня борються за те, щоб мати
на своєму столі питну воду. Я тут,
щоб змінити це, що
існує зараз  Рішення на ринку
дорогі, вимагають частого обслуговування,
часто виходять із ладу, шкідливі для
навколишнього середовища, і їх важко забезпечити.
Прогрес у технологіях дозволив
нам розробити більш стійкі та
екологічно чисті варіанти, які відповідають
еволюційній технології патогенів Melt Water Club
і першим на ринку, який пропонує
надійне довгострокове
рішення чистої
питної води, що не потребує технічного обслуговування, для обслуговування потребуючих громад із
використанням найсучаснішої технології заморожування
важливо враховувати конкретні
потреби та проблеми кожної спільноти
чи регіону. При виборі
системи очищення води враховуйте
довгострокову стійкість  обраного
рішення, враховуючи, що
блоки клубів талої води прості у використанні та можуть бути
встановлені як повністю незалежна
система очищення води, яка працює на
відновлюваному джерелі енергії та забезпечує
чистою водою тисячі людей за
найнижчою ціною,
добре, що ми вже встановили та
експлуатуємо установки  які забезпечують 900
дітей, знайомлячись з програмою «Вода для дітей»,
яка спеціально сконструювала
машину для задоволення потреб трьох
дитячих будинків у регіоні дзюдома.
Вода в регіоні сильно забруднена
металами та нітратами щодо
традиційної системи очищення води.
Практично через часте обслуговування
та високий рівень  витрати на обслуговування,
тому вони зв’язалися з нами, і завдяки цій
програмі ці дитячі будинки тепер мають доступ
до надійного джерела якісної води
щодня.
Ми бачимо, що там є багато
людей, які потребують, тому ми
збираємося орієнтуватися  підтримка
вашого бренду як для технологічних, так і для
наукових досліджень колодязь у Melt
Water Club ми пропонуємо низку
інноваційних рішень для очищення води, щоб
задовольнити різноманітність наших клієнтів,
наша найсучасніша технологія заморожування
дозволяє нам пропонувати різноманітні варіанти,
тому разом із цим ми досліджуємо  наші
версії для дому та комерційні версії, які ви можете
побачити тут на зображеннях, у нас є
патентний шаблон, і наші проекти готові
запустити це майже внутрішнє
самоефективне та стійке джерело
води та льоду, якщо це буде потрібно, у наших будинках і на
підприємствах, ну насправді у мене є  з
них уже більше семи років і
практично нічого не обслуговує, щоб забезпечити
мою сім’ю щоденною питною водою,
крім того, наш глобальний ринок
займає дві третини світового благодійного фонду та Близького
Сходу для наших домашніх і комерційних підрозділів,
де попит високий, а наш процес
пропонує екстремальні  економічні та
функціональні переваги перед існуючими
технологіями, і навіть більше, ми вже
мали привілей працювати з ними,
ми також ведемо розмову з нашими 10
благодійними організаціями та організаціями, які працюють над
забезпеченням людей питною водою, що
призведе до тисячі
-п’яти тисяч замовлень на  наші підрозділи
протягом наступних трьох років і забезпечили
20 мільйонів доларів прибутку,
ну, познайомтеся з нашою командою мрії, яка фактично складається з
дев’яти людей, тут ви можете побачити
основних членів команди, у всіх нас є
20 років інноваційного
досвіду в розробці інновацій
та інших  речі, ми також набули
популярності, ми хочемо нагороду за соціальний вплив,
ну, 2022 ми також є партнерами
Товариства Червоного Хреста України один
грант від usaid також пішов на споживчу
електроніку з usab цього року ми також
працювали з Міністерством електроенергії та
води Кувейту
хм, і не в останню чергу здобув
і отримав сто п’ять тисяч
доларів прибутку в четвертому кварталі
2022 р.
хм, я хотів би завершити сторінку
підкресленням нашої мети, а наша мета
— забезпечити стале,
безкоштовне обслуговування, надійне та довготривале  Довготривале
рішення для очищення чистої питної води для
300 людей протягом трьох років завдяки таким
ініціативам ми наближаємося до
цього, але якщо випадково у вас є
ідея, як прискорити наш вплив і
забезпечити чисту питну воду тим, хто її
потребує, будь ласка,  Ви можете зв’язатися
зі мною в будь-який час. Дуже дякую, дякую
за вашу презентацію Dr
jewelry members
чи є у вас запитання,
оскільки тут усе очищено, дякую,
пане Ендрю, за вашу презентацію, і
так, і
ми запрошуємо наступну третю програму Waste до
Green I  Дрю, мабуть, у Рона у Рона було
запитання, так, я бачив його руку,
так, так, презентація була зосереджена на
проблемах людей, які не мають доступу до води, та все ж таки, коли ви подивилися,
кому ви продаєте, здавалося, що
основні покупці  будуть великі
корпорації та існуючі ресторани,
це дуже різні
ринки, тож це справжня увага на
підводному
населенні чи це кращий
метод очищення для
споживачів із першого світу,
так, дякую за  Питання, Рон,
насправді наш ринок наразі, коли ми
розділили, це приблизно 75 відсотків
організацій і благодійних організацій і 25, це
ті хлопці, про яких ви сказали, що ми
зосередилися на Близькому Сході, аж до
ресторанів, які працюють на ринку,
готелів і приватних будинків
це наша домашня одиниця, яку ви можете
побачити тут ліворуч,
це як транспортний куб,
і ця штука, коли машина
з’єднана з автомобілем у причепі,
це для благодійних фондів і організацій,
тож велике вам спасибі
якщо хтось із наших поважних людей
пам’ятаєш, е-е, маєш якісь запитання, будь ласка,
зараз саме час, мені шкода, чи правильно ти відповів на своє
запитання,
сподіваюся, добре,
дуже дякую, бо
я не бачу жодної реакції, якщо хтось
хотів би поставити додаткові запитання,
будь ласка,
просто залиште будь-яку реакцію, і ми дамо
вам слово
ні, я думаю, ми закінчили так, я думаю, що так,
добре, дякую, а тепер шляхи
до зеленої водневої енергії, будь ласка, слово за
вами,
так, одну хвилинку
ви бачите мою презентацію
так з тих пір, добре,
привіт усім, мене звуть Віра, і моя
команда займається прискореною деградацією
органічних відходів із виробництвом
цінних продуктів, що мають особливе
відношення до зеленого водню.
Середній
біль утворює до однієї тонни органічних
відходів  року, тож постає питання,
що робити з цими відходами. Перший спосіб –
це їх гниття на задньому дворі з
утворенням токсичних сполук і
шкідливих для здоров’я
іншим шляхом – платити за вивезення відходів
на звалища, однак цей спосіб
сприяє зростанню звалищ
теплиць і  зміни клімату,
ми пропонуємо використовувати наш біореактор і наш
гранульований мікробний препарат для
ефективної обробки розчинних органічних
відходів із виробництвом очищеної
води, яку можна використовувати для
поливу саду, а також для ефективного
бродіння твердих органічних відходів із
виробництвом зеленої водневої енергії як
цінним паливом, а також добривом,
яке можна використовувати для підвищення врожайності.
Наша технологія птахівництва цікава
селянам і фермерам в Україні, а
також у країнах Європейського
Співтовариства, особливо в період
сучасної світової енергетичної кризи та
екологічних проблем відповідно до
інтерв’ю з клієнтами. Наші
сегменти клієнтів – це кошти власників будинків Котеджні
містечка Селища та ліхтарі,
ви знаєте, ринок в Україні
досить великий, в Україні є понад 25
000 сіл, де
можна ефективно встановити наш біореактор,
і наша майбутня мета –
ринок Європейського Союзу,
ми  пропонуємо отримати прибуток для нашої
компанії від продажу нашого біореактора
та GMP, а також від обслуговування клієнтів
протягом року, і прибуток для нашого
клієнта – це надійні гроші для
вивезення твердих відходів на звалища.
Енергетична незалежність і, звичайно,
екологічні зусилля
і ось наше досягнення, починаючи
з розробки нашого гранульованого
мікробного препарату, потім оптимізації
процесу деградації відходів,
створення комерційного біореактора,
це успішне польове випробування на фермі
в Україні, і наші подальші плани -
розширити біотехнологію та продажі в
Україні  за кордоном наша мобільна технологія
проста, дешева та автоматична, і ось
переваги наших біотехнологій для
наших клієнтів, по-перше, це енергетична
незалежність для приготування їжі та
опалення будинку завдяки виробництву
високоефективного носія енергії молекулярного
водню, по-друге, це підвищення
врожайності завдяки  до виробництва
біодобрива та очищеної води,
третій момент – це захист навколишнього середовища,
оскільки ми забезпечуємо видалення
гниття та органічних відходів із
заднього двору, і, нарешті, це
внесок у
декарбонізацію атмосфери завдяки виробництву
безвуглецевого палива молекулярного водню,
ось наш  команда, що складається з
мікробіологів та біотехнологів, а
також технічних і електронних
інженерів,
дякую за увагу та
сподіваюся на співпрацю,
дякую за вашу презентацію,
а тепер, дорогий, пам’ятайте, якщо у вас виникли
запитання, будь ласка, посилання,
оскільки все зрозуміло так, е-
е, з тих пір  ми бачили це чітко,
дякую за вашу презентацію та
дякуємо
всім учасникам навчання за
увагу, а
тепер
ми раді вітати наступного
учасника,
так, наступного учасника з
рішеннями для зберігання водню,
привіт усім, мене звати Насер Павлюк.
засновник стартапу зі справжнього зберігання водню
і чому водень, схожий на водень, називають
страхом майбутнього,
а в авангарді процесу
романтичного водню є Європейський Союз
шести, який має повністю декарбонізувати
економіку протягом 20 років, усі ці
наміри вони  ідеально вписується в
концепцію Європейської зеленої угоди 2019,
докладніше в водневу
стратегію для кліматично нейтральної Європи з
липня 2020 року, і яке
місце України в усіх цих процесах, наприклад,
український уряд прагне зробити
Україну водневою парою європейців
минулого року під час  Конференція з відновлення України
Європейська комісія пообіцяла інвестувати загальну суму
47 мільярдів євро в
генерацію водню та транспортні
засоби в Україні в часовому
горизонті до
2013 року. Це досить велика сума, але все
ще існують деякі практичні проблеми
впровадження водню, перша з яких
- це генерація  Я хочу глибше
зрозуміти це, тому що наш стартап
прагне знайти рішення для
проблеми зберігання та транспортування, і
наразі він використовується для зберігання та транспортування
водню під тиском або рідкого
водню при надзвичайно низьких температурах
нижче мінус 253.  градусів Цельсія, і
ці питання є досить проблематичними з
точки зору кількості
транспортованого водню в ціні термінів, щоб сказати,
чому, оскільки водень є найлегшим
хімічним елементом, він дуже пов’язаний,
а також він дуже вибуховий, і ми
працюємо з концепцією металевого
водню.
Коротко кажучи, деякі метали або сплави можуть
просто
поглинати або вміщувати всередину газоподібний водень,
як губка,
використовуючи деяку додаткову температуру та тиск,
а потім водень утримується
всередині гідрату металевого металу, а
потім його також можна вивільнити за
допомогою додаткового  тиск і додаткове тепло,
і на даний момент єдиним робочим
сплавом є лінія з нікелю 5, але він
має недолік, низьку водневу
ємність і високу вартість, або
ліхтар є рідкісним елементом, але
література науково цитує деякі
магнієві NHS на  найкращі майбутні
робочі кандидати, вказуючи на такі фази
та синагній Tunica magnesium до
Cobalt як найвірогідніші кандидати, і
їхньою перевагою є висока об’ємна
кількість водню в організмі, низька вартість
магнію D металів, а також
здатність магнію жовтого кольору є формою
чадроїдів, але все ж  є деякі
проблемні моменти, такі як висока
температура поглинання водню, вивільнення
водню часто може закінчуватися,
а також циклічна стабільність
цих матеріалів, але ми,
використовуючи третій подібний елемент галій,
нам вдалося отримати
формулу магнієвого сплаву до п’яти галонів  три, які
досить добре поглинають і вивільняють водень,
це 2,68 відсотка водню,
але система
посилена вуглецевими трубками та
розглядом можливості цієї
концепції, наприклад,
сталевий циліндр Air Products, який важить 67,5 кілограмів,
містить 724 літри водню.
200 атмосфер один кілограм
стаціонарної мережі поглинає один кілограм становить 68
поглинає і вивільняється з чотирьох
кіллітрів водню і нашого розчину
наша фаза поглинає один кілограм його
поглинає ці
290 літрів водню ми отримуємо
доступ для наукової
розробки та впровадження  цієї
концепції MHS, заснованої на розумінні, нашої бізнес-
моделі ми схожі на зелений стартап у
рамках зеленої трансформації
для промислової революції, яку ми
зосередили на довгостроковій
стабільності, а не лише на
короткострокових прибутках, і наразі ми
Четверта стадія технологічної
лабораторії в Онтаріо, але ми прагнемо створити
робочу систему, яка буде розроблена за
півтора року,
враховуючи, що наша команда складається з п’яти
членів, ми всі молоді науковці
кафедри неорганічної хімії
Живого національного університету, і ми
здебільшого працюють із металевими сплавами,
а саме матеріалами на основі літію,
матеріалами на основі магнію та з
електрохімією, ви можете переглянути наші фотографії
з позиціями в стартапі та у
відділі відповідно, на
цьому все, дякую за вашу увагу,
можливо, у вас є запитання,
дякую за вашу презентацію та
02  пам'ятає, чи
є у вас запитання,
будь ласка, просто залиште відповідь, і
ми дамо вам роботу так, містер Вісма
Уайзмен, ну
так, очевидно, що
ви робите чудову роботу, але це
не була бізнес-пропозиція, це була
наукова стаття  з дрібними
шрифтами, багато графіків і таблиць, які
неможливо зрозуміти за п’ять хвилин,
тож я думаю, що вам потрібна презентація
та інструктаж, і як перетворити цю
блискучу технологію на бізнес-
план, який інвестори зможуть зрозуміти за
п’ять шість сім хвилин, було надзвичайно
важко  стежте за тим, я добре розбираюся в
науці, ви знаєте, я начебто знаю, що
ви робите, але це було
перевантаження інформацією для аудиторії, тому я
думаю, що презентацію потрібно
переробити, оскільки базова
технологія звучить чудово,
дякую за ваш відгук, це  як і
наш перший досвід презентації, ми всі
науковці, але пошук інших подібних
просторів
представляє наші ідеї, з якими ми працюватимемо
в майбутньому.
все зрозуміло, дякую
за вашу презентацію, і ми вітаємо
наступну команду, а
наступна команда — стартове відео,
будь ласка, слово за вами,
все добре з тих пір добре, ми
бачимо вашу презентацію, звук — це
пиво, так,
проектний проект, це проект із мого
першого  однокласник із Гаррісон-
Сіті,
і це про творчий приклад вина
Цільове покоління,
яке відрізняється від інших
списків відтворення на поточний момент більшість
іноземних Більшість
частин енергії виробляється з
викопних
невідновлюваних ресурсів,
вибачте,
ще один новий Ресурси з викопними з
серцями до нашої планети  і весь час, коли
ми видобуваємо їх, спалюємо, втрачаємо результат
цього брудного процесу в транспортуванні
енергії до споживача, крім того,
згідно з оцінками, деякі з цих
ресурсів закінчаться через звичайні десятиліття,
тому йому вдалося витрачати все
більше зусиль на зелені технології  на
сьогоднішньому ринку виробництва енергії ми отримуємо
найкращі результати для двох відновлюваних джерел –
це сонце та вітер. Сонячні елементи мають
кращі показники, але у нас є три загальні
проблеми, тож чому джерело не можна
використовувати для виробництва електроенергії майже
всюди, тому цей ринок
швидко зростає  це робить це
привабливим для бізнесу, однак більшість
підприємств витрачають на широкомасштабне рішення
великі винні турбіни об’єднані інтерколоси
в наукових заводах, ну гонитва за
великими цифрами призводить до втрати
уваги до поточної проблеми
малих користувачів величезна кількість маленьких користувачів
ці користувачі можуть належати до групи споживачів
з обмеженим споживанням електроенергії або до
бізнес-групи з широким діапазоном
споживання, але дуже специфічними потребами,
і наш оригінальний проект є рішенням
для цієї ситуації, ми говоримо, і жорсткий
ринок для малого доступного екологічного
виробництва електроенергії з причин, що  кожен
камінь є безлопатевим генератором, він може усунути
пару або основні недоліки стандартного
генератора зв’язування з лопатями, як приклад,
компактний розмір установки порівняно
з потужністю iTune, який камінь можна
виробляти для різних потреб від половини
до 10 кіловат для пристрою, давайте зробимо його
необхідним і навіть затребуваним  для інших
одночасних рішень, і коли ми говоримо
про
паралельні, ми говоримо про всі типи
навіть на
даний момент, навіть для нашого ринку це рішення, якщо
воно присутнє, може бути дуже корисним для
людей в Україні, крім того, наша мета
створити рішення для ніші, в якій
інші рішення будуть невдалі
найближчим конкурентом для нас є
продукт іспанської компанії Vortex, вони
вже представляють повноцінний робочий
пристрій, але він ще в розробці, і, на
нашу думку, який камінь має кращий
результат для певного напрямку, як показано на
слайдах, тому ми припускаємо, що у нас є
можливо, ми створюємо робочі прототипи,
які також можуть підтвердити концепцію
його цілі двох кіловат максимальної
потужності, ми отримуємо результат, показаний
на слайді, найважливішими з них є
легкий старт із дуже низької мобільності вина
та раціональне використання землі Плюс
зараз ми на стадії деяких
документів і розробки
повноцінної моделі для тестування Life Resource
зовнішніх інвестицій, з яких
скельні проекти розробляються для протипожежних грантів,
а головне питання витрат полягає у
створенні та випробуванні прототипу,
на жаль, ми сповільнили певний процес
через  команда була зайнята,
і щоб надолужити втрачений час, ми
робимо деякі зміни в команді та намагаємось
інтенсифікувати роботу, тому у разі отримання
грантів фонд допоможе покращити
проект у вході, щоб паралізувати деякі
процеси та у створенні мінімальної
змінної MVP  продукт,
а також для деяких інших власних дієслів,
як-от реєстрація патенту, дослідження
можливості сертифікації на основних
ринках для нашого проекту виведення тощо.
Ми розуміємо, що ми
розуміємо лише будинок і щоб стати частиною
ринку з масовим продуктом, нам ще потрібно
багато чого  але ми знаємо шлях, яким ми хочемо
рухатися, і ми будемо збільшувати нашу команду
не тільки спеціальними спеціалістами в
технічній сфері, але й у ринках і так
далі, тому якщо хтось хоче бути частиною
цієї команди, ласкаво
просимо, і якщо у вас є
запитання,
будь ласка, скажіть,
дякую за вашу презентацію, так,
ви точно вчасно, а тепер,
любий Джо, пам’ятає, що
слово за вами,
так, пане, Романе,
будь ласка, у
мене є невелике запитання щодо
масштабування вашого продукту, я не
зовсім зрозумів
хм, що це може бути, ну, ваша головна увага зосереджена
на розробці рішень для B2C або B2B,
я маю на увазі промислове рішення або,
тим більше, для домогосподарств.
Будь ласка, чи можете ви розповісти про це конкретніше,
добре, ми поговоримо про двох
поточних клієнтів, яких ми  можна використовувати, і
це для малого, е-е,
B2B, це для малого бізнесу, який
споживає приблизно
500 кіловат електроенергії на місяць,
і йому потрібно
створити прототип приблизно на 10
кіловат на пристрій, а також для деяких невеликих
клієнтів
з е-м
[Музика]
меншим споживанням і  для цього
споживача буде ефективнішим
від одного кіловата до трьох кіловат на
пристрій,
а тепер моє запитання полягало в тому, чи
сама технологія, яку ви намагаєтеся реалізувати, є
масштабованою для чогось, так, або масштабованою
для промислового використання цих, скажімо,
вітряних турбаністів
як  загальний термін, чи може це підійти для
потенційно
повної електростанції, яка може забезпечувати
деяку кількість домогосподарств, тож,
наприклад, звичайні вітрові турбіни, чи може
цей один партнер бути масштабованим до цього, я
розумію, у нього є проблема з масштабом,
якщо ми говоримо про один пристрій  і
потужність понад 100 кіловат, отже,
приблизно 50 кіловат, це максимальна потужність
для одного пристрою для поточної технології, е-е,
проблема: ми можемо використовувати рослини як вітрові
турбіни за допомогою кількох цих
пристроїв, і з такою кількістю пристроїв
ми можемо масштабувати
наші  обмеження на споживання, але це не дуже
ефективно для дуже великих галузей.
Дякую за відповідь, дякую,
дякую за ваше запитання та
членів вашого журналу,
це обидва так, оскільки я вважаю, що
все вже зрозуміло, а тепер
дякуємо за вашу презентацію та
запитуємо  е-е, команда хоче енергії,
е-е, приєднуйтесь до нас на сцені, що остання команда
в енергетиці та екології.
Пляж, тому слово за
вами
[Музика]
стартап знайдіть енергію так, будь ласка,
добре, ми бачимо презентацію, але ми
вас ще не чуємо,
так
[Музика] е-е
але краще показувати свою
презентацію в повноекранному режимі
з тих пір, добре, зараз все добре,
привіт, мене звати Олександр Стаднік, я
представляю команду, е-е, вітрова енергія, наша команда
пропонує вітрову турбіну з інноваційною
системою самозапуску, що можна використовувати
для освітлення в  місця, які
віддалені від електромережі
Україна використовує 9,2 мільярда кіловат
електроенергії на рік для вуличного
освітлення, тому використання
енергії вітру для освітленого багато для зменшення
викидів парникових газів
турбіна вертикальний ротор мають
проблему запуску мікроелемента традиційно
ця проблема  продається складною
своєю конструкцією
вітрової турбіни з вертикальним ротором,
наша команда запропонувала конструкцію
вітряної енергетики взимку в поєднанні з
вертикальним ротором і змінно орієнтованими
лопатями, що дозволяє багато в чому
вирішує проблему самовстановлення цієї
турбіни.  Працює в двох режимах режими запуску клітини
та режими фігури один і ротор Darius,
які є основними режимами роботи цього
обладнання. Наша команда
виготовила та випробувала моделі, які
пропонуються з цим обладнанням.
Наші переваги: ​​самозапуск
зимової турбіни можливий на
швидкість 2 метри на секунду, тоді як на
роторі Darius потрібно 4 метри на
секунду, а
два накопичення енергії на тридцять
відсотків більше завдяки використанню вітру з
низькою швидкістю.
Тепер наші клієнти в місцевому
уряді – це туристичні об’єкти та
власники ферм.
дуже значний
вплив на навколишнє середовище
від використання енергії вітру, що дозволяє
зменшити викиди двоокису вуглецю
наші
головні наші головні конкуренти в Європі
компанія витримала нерви та одержала кубок
енергії в Україні енергетичний баланс становить
лише чотири відсотки, тоді як у Шотландії
це 60 відсотків, а в Південній Австралії –
80 відсотків
[Музика]
їхні інвестиції у виробництво вітрової
турбіни становлять близько 73 мкм тисяч доларів,
період окупності проекту становить 2,5
роки
[Музика]
– економіст, і дякую за
увагу,
я закінчив  Дякуємо за вашу
презентацію, а тепер, шановний, ви
пам’ятаєте, ми запрошуємо вас поставити своє
запитання про те, що було знайти енергію,
енергію вітру, а що було втрачено, але, безумовно,
не в останню чергу, ух, стартап, ух, хто представляє
категорію ну навколишнє середовище та екологія,
будь ласка, шановні члени журі
слово за вами,
просто залиште будь-яку реакцію
і
дам вам слово,
оскільки все зрозуміло,
велике спасибі за вашу презентацію,
так, ви знову поділіться своїм екраном,
я припускаю, що це було зроблено помилково,
так, звичайно, ви можете вимкнути
трансляцію так  велике вам спасибі,
і тепер ми можемо зробити висновок,
що це було для енергії та
pH навколишнього середовища, ми думаємо, усім
командам і всім суддям за їх важку
роботу та їх час,
ми всі робимо чудову роботу і  ну, ну,
давайте, не чекаючи, почнемо
другу презентацію, і ласкаво просимо, це
другий стартап другої
категорії на сьогодні, це будуть
стартапи, які представляють свої ідеї
в категорії інфраструктури,
тож
дорогі учасники,
ми всі дуже  із задоволенням відкриваю
останню групу сторінок про
галузь інфраструктури та інфраструктурні стартапи,
і першим стартапом, який
представить свою ідею, буде телепорт,
шановний стартап, телепорт, будь ласка, слово за
вами, привіт, так,
мене звуть так, мене звуть
Метро, ​​і я  співзасновник teleporto
stars, який обмінюється мультимодальними
контейнерами,
ми вирішимо проблему
зменшення порожніх пробігів вантажівок із
контейнерами, що доставляються між морськими портами
та складами,
згідно з дослідженням, брак
довіри та координації є двома основними
обмеженнями, що перешкоджають обміну
контейнерами
для авіаекспедиторів дуже важливо
знайти відповідні контейнери від
надійних партнерів, оскільки ціна
вантажу набагато вища за ціну
поїздки, однак цей процес досить
складний через
жорсткі лінії та забирає
багато часу, крім того, життя порожніх контейнерів
без їх заміни за таймером  може призвести
до значних порушень
термінів доставки клієнтам і штрафних санкцій.
Існуючі продукти не зосереджуються на цих
проблемах, тому цей нахил полягає в тому,
щоб вибрати напрямок з одним пробігом порожньої вантажівки,
в результаті 50 контейнерів
доставляються прогонами M2 і лише в
Європі щомісяця  є причиною втрати
20 мільйонів доларів і викидів 70 000
тонн вуглекислого газу.
Телепорт для вправ із розширеною
системою оцінювання та алгоритмом відповідності,
що це допомагає для цього у пошуку
контейнерів,
ми дозволяємо користувачам змінювати свої можливості
Партнери перед угодою та швидко
замінювати  контейнерів, якщо це необхідно, і в
результаті ви можете отримати до 400 доларів
за контейнер
наш цільовий клієнт наші фрі-експедитори,
що працюють із наземним транспортуванням
мультимодальних контейнерів, наша
бізнес-модель полягає в тому, щоб отримувати
комісійні від переваг, отриманих від
кожного контейнера,
на відміну від наших конкурентів, які всі  в
одному конфігураційному рішенні, яке охоплює весь
процес обміну контейнерами,
ми не тільки створюємо надійну мережу для
партнерів, але й дозволяємо їм
ефективно керувати контейнерами та максимізувати
свій прибуток.
Наш ринок становить 2,3 мільярда доларів, і 65
відсотків його не має конкурентів,
тому що ми хочемо  запускати наш продукт в
Україні та Польщі, тому що у нас
там є професійна мережа, і ми можемо
отримати від неї цього клієнта. Це
Туреччина, де, незважаючи на інфляцію,
продовжуються великі обсяги експортних та імпортних поставок,
ці ринки 1,4 мільйона контейнерів
потенційно можуть змінити це  це 70
мільйонів доларів в одному еквіваленті.
Крутий портрет вплив полягає в зменшенні
викидів вуглекислого газу та негативного впливу на дорожню
інфраструктуру
також ми дозволяємо Shipping Lines збільшуватися,
продовжувати знижувати та зменшувати
витрати на зберігання контейнерів, і ми маємо
рекомендації для покращення їхньої діяльності
та бути  більш стійкі до коливань ринку
наразі ми розробляємо наш MVP і
плануємо запуск у травні також у нас є 20
екземплярів листів і ми продовжуємо
попередній продаж.
У нашій команді є два засновники. Ми
маємо 26 років досвіду в цьому та 15
років у логістиці.
Підвищення ста
тисяч доларів 40 на
розробку продукту та 60 на підтримку продажу та
маркетинг,
дякую за увагу, я буду
радий відповісти на ваше запитання,
щиро дякую за вашу презентацію,
а тепер, дорогий, пам’ятайте, якщо у вас виникнуть
запитання, просто залиште свій  реакції тут,
на Zoom-конференції, і ми надамо вам
слово
так, будь ласка, скажіть, пане Ендрю,
тож ви згадали, що клієнти можуть
використовувати вартість до 400 доларів, чи не могли б
ви пояснити одиницю економії, загальну
суму грошей, яку він витратив, і що таке
зниження витрат, яке він міг би отримати від цієї
операції,
так, звичайно, гм, загалом,
гм, експедитори можуть використовувати прямі відправлення
з одним порожнім пробігом, наприклад, якщо у вас
є імпорт, ви ловите свій імпорт і
транспортуєте до One Import зі свого дому,
завантажуєте його та повертаєте назад машину з порожніми
контейнерами  до порту C,
одночасно ви можете експортувати, ви замовляєте
порожній контейнер із sql і транспортуєте
його в контейнери до нашого дому, завантажуйте
туди вантажі та повертайте контейнери для входу
до sipos, і ми пропонуємо
зменшити центральні прогони та після
завантаження імпортувати в наш  будинки ми
транспортуємо порожній контейнер для експорту для
будинку, а потім повертає латинські
контейнери до маршового звіту,
і, наприклад,
ці 400 400 це моє зменшення в тих
самих двох раундах наркотиків і яке
зниження вартості особисто із загальної
суми грошей  Я повинен витратити на свій
контейнер Один імпорт один
Експерти з угод, наприклад, одна особа,
наприклад, одна людина може витратити
до 100 1000 доларів із вашим
контейнером із морських портів, так і
транспортування, і ми можемо заощадити ці
п’ятсот доларів, навколо порожньо, і
коли ми  скоротити центральні раунди, ми можемо
розділити цей прибуток між двома моїми чотирма
замовленнями, і вони можуть отримати вигоду,
добре, дякую [
Музика] дякую
за твоє запитання, любий,
ти пам’ятаєш, якщо хтось хоче
поставити запитання, будь ласка,
це правильний час,
тому дякую  і дякуємо за вашу
презентацію,
а тепер ми вітаємо наступного учасника, будь ласка, слово за
вами, привіт усім, мене звати
Анастасія, я аерокосмічний
інженер, генеральний директор і співзасновник input
soap, це веб-служба
управління авіацією  Рішення для аеропортів і
авіакомпаній.
Пандемія та криза сильно вдарили по авіаційній
галузі та перебільшили багато
проблем, з якими сьогодні стикається керівництво аеропортів.
Авіакомпанії втратили половину своїх пасажирів
і 372 мільярди доларів доходу.
Аеропорти по всьому світу були змушені скоротити
код, закривши частину  інфраструктура
іноземні речі та скорочення заробітної плати,
тож хоча трафік повільно відновлюється,
компанії в індустрії цивілізації зараз
шукають якісь постійні рішення, щоб
почати оптимізувати ресурси та вживати
заходів на основі реальних даних,
тому input soft тут, щоб допомогти, ми
розробляємо два пакети програмного забезпечення, один – це
управління ресурсами  для компаній з наземного обслуговування
та аеропортів і інше
управління даними для авіакомпаній і
компаній з наземного обслуговування в усьому світі за допомогою
цих Рішень ми сподіваємося
збирати дані про кожну операцію
всередині аеропорту, заощаджувати гроші на
заробітній платі та оцифровувати всі
операції
першим офіційним  управління ресурсами,
яке вирішує проблему неефективного
планування людських і технічних
ресурсів, щоб ми могли автоматично
розрахувати необхідну кількість
працівників і обладнання на основі місцевих
авіаційних обмежень, розкладу польотів,
кваліфікації та будь-яких
обмежень, які ви маєте від
профспілок і місцевих органів влади.
для управління ресурсами ми
підключаємося до постачальників супутникових даних,
щоб ми могли аналізувати минулі показники
авіакомпаній, прогнозувати затримки та змінювати
призначення співробітників у режимі реального
часу.
Наш другий сертифікат – це
керування даними, яке допомагає обробляти всі
потоки даних всередині аеропорту  отже,
в основному, ми будемо збирати інформацію
про кожну операцію, пов’язану з під’єднанням
пасажирських сходів і завантаженням,
перевіркою багажу пасажирів, які
проходять безпеку пасажирів, щоб
мати точні дані Kpis і
використання кожного працівника та кожного
обладнання всередині
будівлі терміналу та на рампі з  літак
також є нашим рішенням, ми оцифровуємо
роботу, а також допомагаємо
аеропортам стати екологічнішими, тому ми
сприяємо мінімізації часу
очікування літака з уже ввімкненим
агентом, тому ми зменшуємо викиди вуглекислого газу
та споживання
палива, тому що ми мінімізуємо
затримки в аеропортах по всьому світу
ми монетизуємо платформу за допомогою
системи гнучкої підписки,
і наша ціна залежить від розміру
компаній, які здійснюють операції з кількістю
рейсів на місяць
ринок величезний,
у світі понад 40 000 аеропортів і навіть
більше  компанії наземного транспорту інші
постачальники сторонні постачальники в
аеропортах, які також можуть бути нашими клієнтами,
а також авіакомпанії
Отже, виходячи з цих даних і нашого
дослідження ринку, наш доступний для обслуговування доступний
ринок оцінюється в понад 245 мільйонів
доларів.
Наше рішення є дуже динамічним і
гнучким, і оскільки це одне  з наших великих
переваг для ринку також
наявність сценаріїв правил, заснованих
на нашому власному математичному алгоритмі в
обчисленнях серверної веб-платформи, і
канал супутникових даних для планування в реальному часі
2022 з тестовою роздільною здатністю з
трьома аеропортами в Україні, на іншому сервері
ми були  правильний шлях, тоді
нас зупинила війна,
зараз ми тестуємо нашу платформу
в двох компаніях у Європі, ми
беремо участь у кількох стандартах у
Європі, і зараз я живу в США, тому я
активно досліджую цей ринок і
шукаю нові перспективи  і
зв’язки, у
нас є правильна команда в потрібному
місці, і цим я найбільше пишаюся,
тому що наша команда засновників має великий
досвід понад 20 років у
галузі цивільної авіації, а також у нас є
чудові наставники та радники, тому що ми
підтримуємо  одним із найкращих
акселераторів та інкубаторів у світі
прямо зараз ми закриваємо
півмільйонний раунд збору коштів, який ми вже
підписали, і маємо ще один рахунок, половину
раунду, після чого ми розпочнемо
розширення масштабів на наших географічних
ринках, одночасно завершуючи
розробка двох програмних костюмів і
наймання ключового персоналу,
велике спасибі за увагу та
запрошення за ваші запитання,
велике дякую за вашу презентацію
та участь, дорогі учасники мрії,
так, пане, замініть підлогу,
добре, дякую,
можете повернутися  до слайду з
перевагами ваших конкурентів,
і не могли б ви пояснити, чому попередньо встановлені
сценарії, це головна функція, яка
може допомогти аеропортам заробити більше грошей
і перемогти ваших конкурентів,
так, справа в тому, що авіаційна галузь
дуже суворо регулюється, тому у нас є
багато організацій  які контролюють
кожен крок кожного співробітника всередині
аеропорту, і наша перевага полягає в тому, що наша
компанія вже працювала в
індустрії цивілізації, і ми знаємо всі ці
обмеження 100, тому ми вже включили
всю цю інформацію в розрахунок,
наприклад, у нас є таке правило в усьому світі,
що якщо ви  водій машини для обслуговування води,
ви не можете бути водієм
машини для обслуговування туалетів протягом однієї робочої зміни,
і існує багато таких обмежень, про
які повинні думати диспетчери та менеджери,
коли вони планують
працівників та обладнання, але ми вже
включили це, щоб ви не  Не потрібно думати
про те, що вам просто потрібна інформація
про те, яку
кваліфікацію вони мають, і спільний
розклад польотів, щоб ми
точно знали, коли, скажімо, ви
плануєте польоти на цей рівень, але
вся інша інформація вже є
включено,
це схоже на скорочення часу для
налаштування вашої системи за допомогою нових клієнтів, так,
скорочення часу, але також, як ви знаєте,
мінімізація ризику людського фактору,
тому що під час планування в Excel
або вручну існує багато ризиків, через
які ви не можете запам’ятати все це
обмеження, які ви
повинні об’єднати,
гаразд, і скільки аеропорту ви повинні
підключити до підписки, щоб стати
прибутковою компанією в майбутньому.
залучити п’ятьох клієнтів, але навіть з одним
клієнтом ми вже можемо розпочати запуск і,
як ви знаєте, не йдіть на
серію, щоб посидіти або щось
подібне, тому що наша життєва вартість для
клієнта починається з 500
тисяч доларів, тож в основному
півмільйона — це ціна за все життя, але якщо це
як більший аеропорт або якщо вони хочуть
придбати більше програмних моделей, тому що наші
клієнти можуть купувати е-е, навіть лише
керування ресурсами, де вони можуть купувати
керування ресурсами та керування даними, як-от
система стільникового зв’язку, добре, так, я не
гаразд, дякую, дякую,
дуже дякую, і я бачу, що у
містера Вайзмена також є запитання, будь ласка,
так, це була чудова презентація,
але була одна річ, яка
мене хвилювала в один момент, ти сказав, що ти двигун реального
часу  ще
не готовий, якщо ви
зараз не працюєте в режимі реального часу, тоді як ви
насправді робили достатньо роботи, щоб
підтримувати будь-яку логістику чи
економію операцій, якщо це не реальний
час,
так, модель реального часу
допоможе нам  контролюйте співробітників у режимі
реального часу та контролюйте затримки, але
зараз ми підключаємося до
вже існуючих операційних
баз даних аеропорту. 100 компаній у
галузі цивільної авіації вже мають ці
бази даних, тому що вони повинні дотримуватися
свого розкладу польотів і прямо зараз
без моделі в реальному часі  завдяки нашій
розробці ми використовуємо дані, які
наші клієнти надають нам через свої
бази даних, тому ми підключаємось через
Epi до їхніх уже існуючих баз даних
і отримуємо всю цю
інформацію про час щодо типу
літака, тому що чим більший
літак, тим більше  співробітників, нам потрібно
припинити роботу з іншим обладнанням, але
ми очікуємо, що наш перший
випуск алгоритму рішення в режимі реального часу відбудеться
вже через сім місяців у
липні цього року, тому ми вже
розробляємо його, ми почнемо тестувати його
разом з нашими партнерами в  Європа до
кінця року він буде повністю створений
і готовий до використання
дякую велике дякую
велике дякую якщо хтось має
запитання будь ласка це правильний час
так оскільки все зрозуміло дякую
за вашу презентацію дякую всім
і ласкаво просимо  як колишній учасник
хм
[музика]
ти мене чуєш
так
так так добре так давайте почнемо е-е привіт
мене звуть я
представив наш проект PCB кухня
ну що це за PCB PCB – це
друкована плата, яка є
основою  кожен електронний пристрій, від
вашого смартфона до системи керування Rocket,
і все, що знаходиться між
ними, — це тонкі плати, виготовлені з
ізоляційних матеріалів, таких як скловолокно,
з тонкими шарами провідного матеріалу,
такого як мідь, на поверхні,
у сучасному світі важко знайти
електронний пристрій, який  не використовує друковані плати,
наприклад, материнська плата вашого комп’ютера,
процесор вашого смартфона чи навушники,
мікрофони, все покладається на друковані плати, і
це навіть музичні інструменти, дрони
та ракети мають друковану плату всередині себе.
Оскільки для стартапу ми розуміємо, що
створення прототипів і виробництво високоякісних
друкованих плат є критично важливим  важливий крок у
розробці апаратного забезпечення під час
збоїв, таких як пандемія війни або
війна може бути важко знайти надійні
джерела високоякісних друкованих плат, що призводить до
затримок і втрачених можливостей, тому
наша місія полягає в тому, щоб забезпечити
рішення для цих критичних аспектів у
розробки апаратного забезпечення,
тому, звідки надходять усі ці друковані плати,
зазвичай вони побудовані на великих друкованих платах,
далеко від кінцевих споживачів,
більшість заводів розміщено в Китаї,
а це означає величезні затримки через
доставку під час розробки
інженерів апаратного забезпечення  принаймні, я
підкреслюю, щонайменше від трьох до п’яти
ітерацій друкованих плат, кожне випробування коштує
багато часу, тому
ми хочемо пришвидшити цей процес,
оскільки наша мета полягає в тому, щоб зробити друковану плату за 24
години на 24 квадратних метрах, і
тому ми, е-е, наше рішення  децентралізований
підхід до виробництва друкованих плат, який дозволяє
нам пропонувати надзвичайно швидке створення прототипів
та ітерацію проектів апаратного забезпечення,
що дозволяє нашим клієнтам економити час і
гроші,
однак наша [
Музика]
наше головне завдання полягає в тому, що
наша головна задача полягає в тому, щоб розробити та
оптимізувати процес виробництва маломасштабних друкованих плат
оскільки поточні галузеві
стандарти оптимізовані для виробництва в масштабі життя,
нам потрібно переробити або створити
власні процеси та обладнання для
оптимізації для маломасштабних процесів,
три з чотирьох або п’яти технологічних
закупівель уже розроблено та
перевірено в лабораторії, ми зараз працюємо
над двома іншими  процеси,
в той час як наші китайські конкуренти
пропонують високоякісні друковані плати за низьку ціну,
час першої доставки та місцеве
виробництво пропонують унікальну цінну
пропозицію. Українські друковані плати є
або найбожевільнішим законом, або низькою якістю,
оскільки, або вони базуються на
лініях виробництва
друкованих плат радянської епохи кухня  наразі базується на
хакерському просторі Keith під назвою hack lab, де
ведеться вся розробка. Наш проект знаходиться на
стадії RNG. У нас є два учасники, обидва мають
досвід проектування апаратного забезпечення та
машинобудування.
Дякую за увагу, і я
відкритий для ваших запитань.
Дуже дякую  для вашої презентації,
а зараз тут, щоб запам’ятати, будь ласка,
слово за вами,
якщо у когось є
запитання, так, пане Ендрю, будь ласка, у
мене завжди є запитання, дякую за
презентацію, чи не могли б ви пояснити, так, я
розумію, що
виробнича лінія має бути розташована поблизу
Fabric або де готовий продукт
зібрано чи завершено, тож хто ваші
користувачі, тому що я не знаю багато телевізійного
виробництва в Україні чи поблизу нас,
тому наша робота зосереджена
біля створення прототипів друкованих плат, це величезне
поле, де інженерам потрібно розробляти
власні  проекти, наприклад, будь-який
електронний пристрій на
стадії розробки, вам потрібно кілька кроків
ітерацій, щоб створити прототипи, добре, ви
зосереджуєтеся на компаніях, які
на даний момент створюють прототипи, їм потрібно до 10
одиниць,
тобто п’ять разів із Китаю, щоб визначити так,
порівняти  це тому, що коли ви замовляєте друковані плати
з Китаю, потрібно приблизно один, три-
три тижні, щоб отримати першу партію
друкованих плат, тож п’ять ітерацій, це півроку,
і ваш ринок основним ринком є ​​Європа,
тому що ми хочемо почати в
Україні ваш ринок  тому що Hardware
Community є сильним в Україні, е-е,
розробка апаратного забезпечення, а після цього,
так, ми хочемо вийти на Європу,
гаразд, дякую, дякую
за запитання,
дякую за ваше запитання, і, дорогий,
ти пам’ятаєш, якщо хтось має шанс, будь
ласка,  у
цьому випадку ми думаємо, що pcba Startup
для презентації, і
тепер
ми готові
[Музика]
запросити наступного учасника, е-е, стартап
зелений, іди, будь ласка, слово за тобою,
привіт,
так, ми чуємо, мене
звуть Марія,
і я випереджаю виробництво  з команди Gringo,
ви бачите мій екран,
так, ми бачимо екран,
все гаразд, ось ваша
презентація, будь ласка, почніть, просто мені
дуже шкода, але в плані цієї промови
після того, як тихоокеанська кухня буде
найвищою чи
вибачте, так, пане Янг, чи можете ви
надати слово представнику
так, так, будь
ласка, одну секунду, так, пане
Мері, ми надамо вам
слово за кілька хвилин, а
зараз, будь ласка, 3D-будівля
слово за вами,
ви отримали мою презентацію, так, ми
бачимо вашу презентацію, якщо ви готові,
починає бухгалтерський облік прямо зараз, так, будь ласка,
привіт усім,
мене звати Ян, і сьогодні
я збираюся представити вам
проект під назвою «створення даних для
будівництва
» [  Музика]
прямо зараз, чому в
структурі, зруйновані національними бомбами,
тому нам потрібно будувати міста якомога швидше,
тому наша команда почала
пошук нових будівельних
технологій в умовах
нестабільної роботи великого
будівельного бізнесу,
тому ми маємо  деякий біль у зв’язку
з
нашим
об’єктивом, і вони
[музика]
хм,
деякі рішення для будівництва е-е,
ми побудуємо нові, використовуючи їхню
технологію друку,
наші цілі — це не
лише будівництво, але й
зробити нові міста елегантними та  дуже
приємно
працювати над дизайном у нашій лабораторії,
ми будуємо малі архітектурні форми з
надрукованих
елементів
[Музика],
і ви можете бачити
[Музика]
час створення в нашій команді [
Музика],
тому наша конкурентоспроможність у
Данії — це велика швидкість усіх
рух це близько двох-трьох днів
[Музика]
хм
це залежить від
складності
будівництва
ми пофарбували
конструкцію будівлі Unico
мінімальна потреба у виробництві Персонал
проста логістична система та середня
ринкова вартість проектів та багато
інших
переваг
на даний момент наші клієнти добре зосереджені
це люди, які зацікавлені в
креативних рішеннях, це
студії, ресторани, школи, лікарні, за
якими штатами і, звичайно, місцеві
органи влади,
які ведуть у проектуванні шахт,
наші канали збуту дешевші ринки,
рекомендації місцевих органів влади і,
звичайно, Інтернет,
нове,
як ми можемо заробляти гроші  скажімо, продаж
конструкцій, ми можемо
надати пов’язані архітектурні
послуги, продаж додаткових моделей,
якщо ви
хочете зробити якусь іншу функцію для
свого проекту,
зовнішню рекламу в додатку та
підтвердити партнерство, щоб ми могли створити
веб-сайт цього,
скажімо, принтери на  Україна,
наші потреби, я не
даю нам, тому що наш старий принтер, на якому
ми робимо наші останні проекти, і я маю
багато технічних помилок,
а у вас є трохи точності
та багато інших
цілей, які неможливо
реалізовувати
багато проектів,
тому
нам потрібно для нових принтерів
000 Героїв і для будівництва наступних
туристів 2 000 ярусів
[Музика] ну
це наша команда ну паливо це студенти
Головного національного університету
будівництва та архітектури і це
наші контакти дякую за  ваша
увага, я готовий до ваших
запитань,
дякую за вашу презентацію, а тепер ви можете
запам’ятати
час для ваших запитань, будь ласка,
просто залиште будь-яку реакцію тут, у
конференції Zoom, так, пане Ендрю, будь ласка,
привіт молодий, дякую, презентація,
але якщо ви зосередитесь на  вашій презентації або
на унікальній формі та швидкості виробництва
гм вам слід зосередитись на моделі та деякій
дизайнерській
проповіді не для відновлення України, де
нам потрібні мільйони квадратних метрів
вам слід зосередитись на якійсь
унікальній гмм
високоприбутковій елегантній сфері дизайну
гмм,
а тому що
думали  конкурентних переваг, і якби у
нас
було кілька принтерів, ми могли б зробити
будинки
не в місті, а в
об’єктиві [Музика],
як я розумію, я зрозумів із
презентації, ви могли б надрукувати
невеликі деталі дизайну будинку чи щось
Елементи дизайну, а не
компоненти для будівель,
ні,
ви також можете надрукувати
будинки, ніби ви бачите, це
фотографії на цьому слайді,
і яку кількість компонентів ви можете
надрукувати на своєму 3D-принтері з цієї моделі,
це все з принтера, так,
це все для
Windows, але  лише
ці окуляри та, можливо, дерев’яні
сходи. Я знаю, що це надруковано,
добре, якщо ви могли б, цікаво
дізнатися про порівняння цін,
наприклад, на звичайні будівельні матеріали
з. Я не думаю, що це будівля площею 50 квадратних
метрів, і ваше рішення для
порівняння ціни на  ваше рішення та для
звичайного процесу будівництва будинків,
гм, у мене є ці
документи
для наступного разу, коли ви отримаєте 88 до кількох додаткових
слайдів, і якщо ви отримаєте кілька
запитань, дякую, гаразд, дуже дякую
за ваші запитання,
іноземці,
оскільки все зрозуміло, давайте, гм,
Пол  дякую та
гмм, дякую пану Яну, представнику 3D-складання,
а тепер ми з радістю запрошуємо в Грін, ідіть,
будь ласка, слово за вами,
привіт ще раз,
це гарний день для знайомства,
і я радий вас усіх бачити, а чи можу я
сказати, що  завдяки сьогоднішньому виступу Кевіна,
дозвольте мені представити себе та
іншу компанію,
мене звуть Марія, я займаюсь виробництвом Hadoop,
ця невелика, але дуже пишаюся цим, ми
команда харчових технологій,
хто мріяв жити й розвиватися
без жорстокості та зміни клімату, я
вибачте, ви можете переглянути мою презентацію
так, ми бачимо презентацію, але вона
не в повноекранному режимі так, зараз
все добре,
але я маю, хм, дякую, у мене є невеликі
проблеми, щоб змінити свої рейси,
хм
про нас
ми ті, хто створив в Україні
названа нарізаною рослинною основою Піонер серед
третього покоління рослинних
альтернатив ми цілковито українці
всі люди іншої команди
висококваліфіковані діти наша місія зробити
інноваційні рослинні продукти харчування
дівчата смачними та доступними для всіх
чому тому що
планета
справді
потрібна  допоможіть
це вже відомий факт, що
за виробництвом м’яса, збільшенням споживання, стоїть багато проблем для нашої планети,
продукти рослинного походження, які допомагають
уповільнити зміну клімату, тож якщо ви хочете
добитися голосування, нам слід змінити свій
раціон
іноземна
індустрія мільярдів доларів відповідно до
прогноз Загальний ринок рослинної продукції
зросте протягом наступних восьми років, крім того,
зростаюча категорія – це риба та
харчові альтернативи
Рослинна промисловість має прогалини
нереалістичний вигляд привабливість поганий смак смак
запах і неприродне приготування
Поведінка, в яку ми повинні вірити та масштаб
вгору Інновації у нас є шість два перші
пункти, а також півкуля
світ більше не ділиться на
м’ясоїдів і веганів, створюючи продукти рослинного походження,
які виглядають як м’ясні вироби,
підтримують культуру
споживання традиційних звичних
продуктів, але з повагою та
врахуванням переваг
всі зустрічаються та рослинні продукти
повинні бути представлені в тому самому меню в одному
супермаркеті та споживатися за одним столом.
ми створюємо самі інноваційні продукти наш
асортимент включає інноваційні
продукти та класичні продукти
на даний момент наші продукти представлені
в кількох роздрібних змінах у  у
місті Києві та в приватних магазинах
по всій країні
люди –
це наша головна проблема, у
нас чудова команда відважних професіоналів,
яка може працювати з будь-ким у будь-яких умовах
[Музика]
і останнє, що я хочу зазначити, у
нас уже є багато
маємо впізнаваний бренд та ідентифікаційний асортимент
працездатного асортименту продуктів, включаючи дивовижний
продукт і звичайні продукти перевірені та
налагоджені технології обробляють
вибраних постачальників сировини та
спеціального обладнання
в тому, як послуги, такі як RND та
команда ароматизаторів, і велика любов до нашої роботи на рослинній основі,
тому велике вам спасибі
дуже дякую за вашу презентацію,
а тепер настав час для запитань, які
ще потрібно запам’ятати, будь ласка,
третє за вами,
просто залиште будь-яку реакцію, і ми дамо
вам слово так,
пане Ендрю, будь ласка, е-
е, Марія, ви можете ввімкнути презентацію,
так,
це дуже цікаво  щоб зрозуміти,
навіщо вам потрібні інвестиції,
добре, сума інвестицій, я бачив, добре,
виробництво, це невелике виробництво та
потужність, е-е, майже 50 кілограмів на день,
тому ми даємо, нам потрібні гроші, щоб купити
спеціальне обладнання, наприклад камери чи
морозильні камери, або, можливо, це е-е
можливо, холодильна кімната для зберігання наших продуктів
у ринковій упаковці
мм-хм, це те, про що ми говоримо,
це півмільйона на обладнання та
ще один на експлуатацію як експлуатаційні витрати,
я думаю, нам потрібно е-е-е-е, два мільйони
років, щоб почати
будувати е-е  велике виробництво, яке ми
маємо зараз, тому що нам потрібна така
потужність або може підтримувати, наприклад,
дві тонни на день, але зараз ми маємо
таку потужність, наприклад 50 кілограмів на день,
і чи не могли б ви запустити деяке обладнання
на заводах у Європі  чи США,
щоб
не витрачати інвестиції на купівлю грошей, у
нас є рішення
для розподілу,
це потрібно, наприклад, ми можемо
заробити на вихідні,
гм, ми
можемо отримати на нашу роботу стільки працівників,
і гм,
ми можемо збільшити кількість робочих рук  або
виробництво, наприклад,
не е-е, наприклад, пакувальна машина
або гм та інші речі, або формувальна
машина і замінити її ручна робота е-е-е,
ми е-е не
досліджуємо е-е можливість орендувати це,
тому що це не
гм
торкнутися е-е поставки в Україні я думаю
так, але, як я розумію, ви
орієнтуєтеся на ринок Європи та США не лише
для України,
і якщо ви просто орендуєте, ви можете досягти
своїх цілей швидше,
ми досліджуємо співпрацю з
уже
запущеним виробництвом у Європі та використовуємо це
обладнання, щоб зробити  наш продукт,
наприклад, співпраця, це е-е, виробництво в
Європі,
гм, я
думаю, гм,
здатність створити щось,
наприклад, це біля кордону з
Європейським Союзом, наприклад,
я розумію, гаразд, удачі, я
дякую за презентацію, і вам
добре  візуальні матеріали для ваших продуктів,
дякую, шановний Ендрюсе, дякую, що ви
так активні, щоб пам’ятати, е-е, і за
ваші запитання, е-е, якщо хтось хоче
поставити запитання, будь ласка,
добре,
оскільки все зрозуміло, давайте, е-е,
запросимо спасибі Мері за вашу
презентацію, і менше, і чому  наступний
учасник, цеглинки Lego Echo, будь ласка,
сцена ваша,
доброго дня, Марія, доброго дня
нашому інвестору та доброго дня всім
учасникам цієї події, приємно
познайомитися, мене звати,
я член команди Меморіального
коледжу будівництва та архітектури
навіть це національний аграрний університет,
сьогодні ми хочемо представити вам і ваш
будівельний матеріал, він називається цеглинка Lego Echo,
ну, яка головна ідея,
адже не секрет, що в нашій
країні як найвимогливіша галузь
промисловість, оскільки
ситуації, які ми маємо зараз, і
через війну, яка є в нашій
країні на території нашої України,
багато будинків і багато будівель було
зруйновано, і
ми повинні будувати їх заново,
відновлювати ремонт і навіть з першої
цегли ми повинні будувати  їх знову,
і ось питання, як це зробити
швидко, як зробити це ефективно і не
витрачати занадто багато грошей, оскільки наш Economist
пропонує багато, і ідея полягає в цеглині ​​LEGO.
Одним із способів
мінімізації витрат на будівництво є
виробництво  цеглинок
Лего цеглинка - це полуторна вбудована
цеглинка, схожа на ідею дитячого
конструктора
переваги видно кожна велика має
чотири канавки їх можна класти швидше і
простіше
наявні отвори можна використовувати для проводки
вага Лего цегли менша  порівняно з
іншими типами цегли,
що є інновацією, це ідеальний варіант
для будівництва
красивого зовнішнього вигляду, поки ви
будуєте стіни, ви можете будувати
будинки різної конструкції
Далі Перевагою є швидкість це означає, що
процес будівництва швидкий і
точний,
також є можливість  закладання
вірусу в кожну
цеглину дуже важливо, оскільки сьогодні наші
будинки мають багато вірусів,
мабуть, здається, що ми зекономимо
використання Manson real за допомогою спеціального клею,
а тепер я хочу поговорити про
переваги смуги йде втричі
швидше, ніж  звичайний Brick Lane надсилає до
унікальної комбінації шипів і
канавок 25 кілограмів клею достатньо
для 500 шматків цегли, це
економічніше порівняно зі звичайною цеглою,
і ми також можемо виробляти перероблені пластикові
цеглини, виготовлені з подрібненого та
переробленого пластику
відсутність цегли  стають дуже популярними,
а цегляна печатка дуже швидко зростає
через цінність продукту
мінімальні фінансові інвестиції для
початку виробництва кубиків Lego
під час виробництва цих
кубиків можна додавати пігмент
і отримувати різні стовпчики
цеглинок
приголомшливо створювати можна створювати
різні форми ще однією перевагою є
нитки, оскільки кубики Lego можна використовувати для
будівництва несучих стін,
тож яка технологія виробництва
основними компонентами є подрібнений
вапняковий водний цемент і певний барвистий
пігмент приблизно
1006 600 кілограмів подрібненого вапняку
і 220 кілограмів цементу
знадобиться для одного кубічного метра готового
каменю
гм все, що нам потрібно побудувати,
щоб виробити гм цю цеглу, ви можете побачити в
презентації
гм інше щодо конкурентів
інші конкуренти
гм це цегельна компанія, розташована в
Україні в  Регіон Івана Френсіс, тож ви
кажете, що справді
хм
доктора використовували українці,
тож, як висновок, цеглинки Лего — це
просте та сучасне рішення для створення
неймовірних будинків,
вони є учасниками нашої команди на
екрані так, ви бачите наших
учасників,
дякую вам за  Вашій увазі,
і я хочу додати, що оскільки ми працюємо над
будівництвом коледжу будівництва та
архітектури коледжу, у нашому коледжі
повно професіоналів,
дуже кваліфікованих магістрів, але в
той же час у нас є інновації, і якщо у
нас є така можливість, ми можемо реалізувати нашу ідею
це означає, що ми матимемо
висококваліфікованих спеціалістів, яких ми
готуємо, я маю на увазі наших студентів, і
за допомогою таких матеріалів
наші студенти, наші
майбутні професіонали створюватимуть дуже
гарні та дуже ефективні будинки в нашій
Україні, і я вважаю, що в  деякі дні
в деякі місяці країна буде
красивою буде оновлена ​​або матиме
гарні будинки, і ми матимемо мир
і щасливе життя тут, на нашій землі,
дякую,
велике спасибі за вашу презентацію
та за вашу соціальну е-е-е-е-е-е, впливову роботу
е-е, дорогі спогади  будь ласка,
настав час для запитань і відповідей,
просто залиште реакцію, і ми дамо
вам слово
нуль, ви пам’ятаєте, якщо хтось хоче
почати розмову
[Музика]
ви знаєте, якщо е-е,
після презентації немає питань, це означає, що ваша
презентація була  справді чудово, ви бачите в
нашій професійній сфері вчителів, якщо ми
запитуємо студентів про запитання, і
вони не мають жодних запитань, це означає,
що тема була справді дуже
інформативною та без питань, або вона
була
взагалі зрозумілою, і попередній варіант
кращий  Я більш ніж впевнений, що в
першому варіанті, ну, велике спасибі за
презентацію, а
тепер, вітаємо наступний стартап, який
представить ідею вторгнення, це
переробка відходів природного каменю,
будь ласка, слово за вами,
ми бачимо вашу презентацію  але ми
вас не чуємо, так, добре, привіт, привіт
усім так, мене звуть Артур
Махнер, і я радий представити наш
промисловий проект під назвою restone,
що означає переробку
природних
відходів у печі, і я хотів би почати з
короткого  теоретичне підґрунтя
цієї проблеми,
і поки що Україна, наскільки вам відомо,
нараховує понад 17 відсотків
родовищ бабки у світі, а кам’яний
шлам є органічним відходом виробництва, що
виникає внаслідок процесів різання та
полірування та великої кількості
кам’яного пилу  виробляються щорічно, а
утилізація цього каміння також стала
серйозною проблемою, і імператори
намагаються з’ясувати, чи можна
використовувати великі відходи Стоуна як
наповнювач для виробництва
цеглин із лосося та
сільськогосподарського сектора, як новий підхід,
тому я  Я хотів би незабаром представити нашу команду,
це ключові люди, ми обидва є
співзасновниками компанії eucharistone, це
Володимир Левинський і я, Артур
Магна, а також деякі люди за
сценою, і ми обидва маємо
теоретичну наукову підготовку, а
також досвід  досить досвідчений
у промисловому дизайні та міжнародних
наукових проектах,
і значна кількість відходів
утворюється під час виробництва
виробів з натурального каменю, наприклад,
Granny Collaborate Gabra та інших
декоративних каменів, і це рідкі
відходи, це може бути двома можливими шляхами,
так, усе це  відходи рідкі відходи ми називаємо
це шламом, це суміш кам’яного
пилу та твердих відходів, які є стружками,
і ми маємо оцінку, як
раніше є наше дослідження, і ми
просто вважаємо, що в нашому регіоні ми
представляємо область гробниці, це
досить  Багаті родовищами корисних копалин
зараз працюють приблизно
350 компаній, і загалом вони
видобувають понад 10 000
кубічних метрів каміння, великі відходи, це
жахлива кількість, і, як ви бачите
на цьому слайді, це спричинило великі
екологічні проблеми через  просто
викинувши на ландшафт таку
кількість відходів кам’яного шламу, тож ми
збираємося вирішити цю проблему, і ми
почали раніше, ми почали проводити деякі
попередні дослідження щодо можливих
способів використання цих відходів шламу з природного каменю
для сушіння будівельних сумішей, як
наповнювач для  будівельні суміші, а також ми
намагаємося
[Музика]
як наповнювач для кераміки, а
наші попередні дослідження щодо
хімічного та зернистого хронометричного
складу гранітної суспензії Штати
просто допомогли нам відкрити та
розробити цю технологію, а також ми були
розроблені як спеціальні  система переробки
та зневоднення для виділення шламових відходів,
які ми можемо напівпродуктом, який ми можемо використовувати
для подальших кроків у нашій технології,
ми можемо бачити ці відходи після зволоження
як сухі шматки, а також ми спроектували
промислові в рамках нашого процесу, як цей
сайт для переробки твердих  і рідкі
кам’яні відходи 15 гектарів поблизу
коралової станції Сіті, і, як ви бачите,
це можливі шляхи, якими ми виробляємо, і
ми можемо додати за е-м. Кам’яний мул відходів для
басейну лосося Смертельні показує справді хороші
результати, ми зробили це у співпраці з
сім кварталів  фактор у ударнику це
щойно збільшено на 20 відсотків
всеосяжних сильних сторін статусу, а також
коли ми використовуємо це відходи для
виробництва цегли, це також покращує
властивості, механічні та фізичні
властивості, ми також провели це дослідження
у співпраці з компанією
та наступним текстом  крок, який ми збираємося
зробити, щоб фактично вимагати
додаткових витрат, це можливість використовувати
повільну гонку Stone sludge race в сільськогосподарському
секторі, як-от добриво та
поглинач води, нам потрібні ці гроші лише для
проведення додаткових тестів у
сільськогосподарській моделі Laboratories test для в
сільськогосподарські поля, а також
отримати цю сертифікацію відповідно до
європейських стандартів, це наш наступний танець,
наступні кроки, які ми збираємося зробити, це те,
чому ми просимо ці додаткові
гроші на стартап, тому я намагався
бути точним у п’ять хвилин  пішов,
велике дякую за увагу, я
готовий відповісти на ваші можливі запитання, велике спасибі,
презентація,
червень, учасники, будь ласка, настав час для
запитань і відповідей, е-е,
ми працюємо в тому самому ми так, пане Ендрю, будь
ласка, слово за вами,
дякую за  презентація та
як я зрозумів, я зрозумів, що ви
проводили це дослідження лише для того, щоб зрозуміти
фізичні чи механічні
переваги використання цього нахилу в
будівництві чи будівництві чи є у вас
економічні розрахунки, так, ми
це зробили також ми зробили  Цей розрахунок,
наприклад, ми щойно підрахували, що
собівартість отримання цього, е-е, необхідно
зробити, щоб забезпечити зволоження цих
відходів кам’яного шламу, спричиняє приблизно 30 35
доларів за патолу бензину, а також ми
можемо просто вирішити це для цієї компанії для
промисловості, наприклад, за п’ятдесят тисяч  п’ятдесят
доларів за тонну, тож, ймовірно, це приблизно
15-20 доларів за тонну. Дохід
був би таким, як наш розрахунок, і ми
просто проводили це дослідження, і
ми побачили величезний попит на цей
продукт з боку сільськогосподарських компаній,
усі були здивовані, начебто добре,
це  дуже цікаво, ми збираємося спробувати
цю технологію, чому б і ні. Так,
чесно кажучи, зараз це великий інтерес, але
зараз ми просто надаємо кілька невеликих коротких
тестів у лабораторії, і ми
збираємося просто надати цей тест у
сільськогосподарському  полів і побачити, як це
мінерали збільшуються в
компонентах так, викопних
компонентів також він працює, як
водопоглинач, тому що він також дуже
корисний, характерний для
сільськогосподарських компаній, добре, це стосується
сільського господарства,
машинобудування  працювати з полями, заповненими
камінням, так, це звучить
дивно з одного боку, але це я, я
думаю, це майбутнє, тому що ми
можемо просто використовувати ці мінерали повторно, це
компоненти мінералів, які тверді також
потребують мінералів, але як забезпечити цю
технологію  Я вважаю, що дуже важливо
закінчити наше дослідження
в рамках цієї ідеї, чи дешевше використовувати
ваше рішення, навіть
я думаю, що воно використало ту саму ідею, щоб
збалансувати водний баланс, е-е, всередині, ви знаєте,
що
в нашому регіоні є величезні екологічні проблеми  тому що багато
компаній просто викидають ці
відходи кам’яних шматків на основі шламу, і після того, як ми
просто можемо запропонувати їх за невелику ціну, щоб
купити їх для повторного використання та забезпечити їх
для технологій для сільського господарства та
секцій, тому що за цеглу за
деякі невеликі  seven Motors це працює дуже
добре, це просто збільшує дохід для
компаній, але ми тільки розпочали цей наш
шлях до впровадження цієї технології, і
ми збираємося зробити це лише для того, щоб
розширити її в різних секторах
економіки, гаразд, дякую, бажаю всього
найкращого
дякую, велике дякую за ваше
запитання,
дякую за ваше запитання, ви
пам’ятаєте,
якщо у вас є запитання, будь ласка, не соромтеся,
якщо все зрозуміло, ми дякуємо вам за
репрезентацію,
ласкаво просимо, а тепер, ну, ми ласкаво просимо стартовий
куточок,
будь ласка,
слово  ваш,
дякую, я ділюся своїм екраном,
чи можете ви побачити мій екран зараз,
так, усе гаразд, будь ласка, почніть, тож
привіт усім,
ми в кутку, і ми вирішуємо
найбільшу проблему у світі, здогадайтеся, що це
правильно, це ремонт будинку Куточок
створює готовий до встановлення  дизайнерські
кухні, які можна замовити в два
кліки,
світ змінився, і багато людей
почали працювати віддалено згідно зі
статистикою 74, наразі вони працюють повністю
віддалено або гібридно,
одночасно
43 мільйони
домовласників у США
не мають доступу до якості
доступні за часом
кухні та ванні кімнати
для ремонту будинків,
ну, компанії в США
пропонують досить застарілі матеріали та
рішення,
оскільки вони мають більш традиційну та
дешевшу
якість, щоб запропонувати аудиторії,
тому ми вирішили будувати кутові,
а Corner робить
високоякісними та екологічно чистими  кухні
доступні та доступні для
власників будинків у США.
наша місія полягає в тому, що ми віримо, що
кожен заслуговує на гарний та
персоналізований домашній інтер’єр Джо
одночасно за доступною ціною.
наші кухні виготовляються в Україні з
використанням роботизованого обладнання
та високоточних технологій
[Музика]
нам подобається  повністю нестандартні
матеріали та продукти,
оскільки середній вік дому в
США становить близько 60 років, і є
багато приміщень, які дуже відрізняються,
і ми повинні
підібрати з точки зору простору та розмірів усі
матеріали та зробити його красивим та
відповідає дизайну, який
шукає домовласник,
у той же час
ми використовуємо стійкі матеріали для
виготовлення наших кухонь, використовуючи або
перероблені шафи, або матеріали з
відповідального лісового господарства та намагаючись
мінімізувати вплив вуглецю на
навколишнє середовище,
і в той же час
хто має  платформа, на
якій наші користувачі можуть замовити
ремонт своєї кухні, вони можуть вибрати
Дизайни,
побачити різні категорії матеріалів,
побачити ціни, розрахувати їхню оцінку
та відстежувати прогрес за допомогою нашого онлайн-
інструменту,
це допомагає автоматизувати процес і
зробити роботу дуже легкою для
кінцевого користувача.
окрім цього, існував величезний і
невикористаний ринок, який становить 130 мільярдів
доларів на ремонт будинків і самих кухонь,
і це, до речі, другий за величиною
обсяг для власників будинків у США.
Нашими головними конкурентами є Ikea та
Home Depot,
проте
ми пропонуємо інший тип
продукту, оскільки
ці гравці мають обмежений
вибір нижчої якості, і дуже часто
більшість товарів просто немає в
наявності, і вам потрібно чекати
три п’ять шість місяців, щоб мати можливість
замовити всі елементи для
ремонту кухні, які вам
уже потрібні  маємо наших перших клієнтів у
США, що підтверджує, що наш продукт
актуальний для цільової аудиторії,
цього року ми також представили наше рішення на виставці CES і привернули
велику увагу потенційних
клієнтів,
а також будівельників-розробників,
які
вважають, що це рішення може їм допомогти
щоб підвищити свою маржу,
де Україна заснувала стартап proptech
із сильною командою, яка має досвід
у будівництві,
а
ми маємо досвід у технологіях, які
допомагають нам створювати онлайн-платформу
та програмне забезпечення,
ми також маємо досвід у
розробці та
успішному прямому зверненні до споживчих
брендів у  масивні ринки
записуються
це наша дорожня карта на наступному кроці ми
плануємо додати штучний інтелект для
автоматизації дизайну, щоб користувач міг
миттєво побачити потенційний дизайн своєї
кухні
в той же час ми бачимо, що якщо ми додамо
послуги встановлення, ми можемо збільшити
цінність для наших клієнтів
за один рік, ми плануємо побудувати
виробничі потужності в США, щоб мати
можливість попередньо зібрати всі кухні
ближче до дому клієнта та запустити
нові вертикалі
на підсумку, ми працюємо над
величезною та невикористаною 130  ринок мільярдів доларів
і створити нову категорію
доступних кухонь преміум-класу в США
з повністю онлайн-досвідом, коли справа
доходить до купівлі та управління ремонтом будинку,
і ми вже маємо перевірку з нашими
першими клієнтами в США, і нашими наступними
кроками є впровадження штучного
інтелект та додаткові послуги з інсталяції
ми поєднуємо українську якість з американськими
цінностями, мене звуть Коста Міска, дякую,
ми будемо раді відповісти на ваші запитання,
дякую за вашу презентацію, шановні
члени журі, будь ласка, настав час для
сесії Q і T,
адже всі
так, будь ласка,
зробіть  запам’ятайте, просто залиште будь-яку
реакцію, і ми надамо вам звіт,
пане Ендрю, будь ласка,
гм, дякую за презентацію, чи не могли б
ви порівняти
як частину так, частину логістики в
колі клієнтів від Pain до або я не
знаю від вибору дизайну до  отримавши
його замовлення, чи
можна доставити та виготовити
меблі в Україні, а потім відправити вас
до США?
Так, це чудове запитання, я
спробую надати більше інформації в
процесі, тому на першому кроці
є такий дизайн, як  ви
згадали, тому ми працюємо з користувачем, щоб
завершити дизайн, у нас уже є
шаблони дизайну на нашому веб-сайті, а потім
ми зв’язуємо клієнта з
професійним дизайнером для створення
візуалізацій та архітектурних планів, щоб мати
можливість створити специфікації матеріалів,
щоб ми могли запустити проект  на
виробництво
це займає в середньому два тижні, а потім,
коли ми маємо всі ці архітектурні
плани, ми можемо надіслати ці деталі на
виробництво, і час виробництва становить
два тижні, тож через два тижні ми отримуємо повністю
виготовлені на замовлення шафи та інші матеріали, які
будуть готові до відправлення  до нас ми працюємо
з логістичною компанією, яка
доставляє цей продукт через Європу, як-от
Румунія чи Польща, це займає ще
один тиждень, а потім ми здійснюємо
доставку за кордон, це займає приблизно шість тижнів
до центру виконання робіт у США, а
в США ми робимо  остання миля доставки
до клієнта, але в той же
час це весь процес, яким
керує логістична компанія, у них
є схожі рамкові процеси, щоб це зробити,
це досить звично для
продається багато європейських меблів  на ринку США, але
має досить високу ціну, у нашому випадку він
доступніший, вища якість, тому він
виділяється серед конкурентів
тут, а з точки зору логістики,
щоб доставити його до США, потрібно ще шість тижнів,
але це досить часто  Випадок використання
добре, дякую,
дуже дякую, члени JoJo, це
останній дзвінок
для запитань,
добре,
добре, ми дякуємо стартап-куточку за
їхню презентацію так, ми з радістю
вітаємо стартап zelly
або виступаємо, привіт, привіт,
мене звуть Олена  ну, я
співзасновник і є CCO, це zilli zilli — це
український стартап, і сер, це
перший мобільний Webster net Builder,
який допомагає власникам малого та мікробізнесу
миттєво почати продавати в Інтернеті
зі своїх телефонів,
тому ми збільшили наш  виросли
вчетверо всього за п’ять місяців і отримали більше
сорока п’яти тисяч доларів
імператора, гаразд, чи знаєте ви, що
вісімдесят відсотків власників мікро- та малого
бізнесу використовують телефон як
єдиний пристрій, тому власники цього бізнесу
наразі не мають інструментів?  розпочати
онлайн-розпочати онлайн-продажі
з телефону
гм і хропіти гроші речі та
досвід для ефективних онлайн-продажів
більше 40 мільйонів мікропідприємців
у Сполучених Штатах,
Великобританії, а також в Австралії стикаються з цією
проблемою
існуючі рішення не вирішують  це
не перші продукти для мобільних пристроїв, їм бракує
інструментів просування та функцій штучного інтелекту, які
обмежують кількість клієнтів, ми
вирішили, що настав час змінити
гру, тому ми створили zilli,
найсучасніше рішення для
онлайн-продажів, а зараз  коли підприємцям потрібно бути
присутніми в Інтернеті, вони завантажують
дурну програму та за допомогою нашого штучного інтелекту вони
створюють самоорієнтований веб-магазин за
лічені секунди, коли вони хочуть охопити більш
цільову аудиторію, щоб залучити більше
клієнтів, вони запускають
рекламу на основі штучного інтелекту на Facebook Google і Tick
Tock  з нашим мобільним додатком,
коли вони хочуть почати, це почати
отримувати онлайн-платежі від
своїх клієнтів, вони можуть легко додати
кнопки Apple Pay і You Pay до своїх онлайн-
магазинів завдяки нашій інтеграції зі
stripe,
наразі у нас є понад 7 000 викладачів
із  Сполучені Штати Об’єднане Королівство
Бразилія Мексика та Чилі ці люди –
юристи, роздрібні торговці, тренери та навіть
розробники NFC. Ми бачимо, що користувачі вважали, що
ми можемо об’єднати всі функції,
необхідні їм для ведення онлайн-бізнесу,
в одному місці, і ми знаємо це, оскільки
наше утримання  показник після чотирьох місяців
використання продукту становить понад 80
відсотків,
ми створюємо
цей продукт із супер українською
командою, а зараз я розповім вам більше про
фонтанну команду daily we, наш
співзасновник Діма має понад 11 років
досвіду  у технічному керівництві,
перші три роки він працював із Google
AdSense, е-е, наша засновницька лабораторія має
понад п’ять років досвіду в
управлінні великими відділами продажів для
аутсорсингових агенцій і приносить
дохід понад один мільйон доларів
на рік, а я — понад чотири роки
досвід у сфері комунікацій Я
раніше працював із walk lsmo, ну
бізнес Memorial of zilli — це SAS, ми
також маємо семиденний випробувальний період, а наша
місячна підписка починається від 38
доларів, ми знайшли, що наш продукт
відповідає ринку наших блакитних океанів, працюючи з
реферальними програмами впливових людей  а також
платна реклама на різних
каналах сторінок, таких як Facebook, Instagram,
Google і Tick Tock, і завдяки цьому
зараз ми щомісяця залучаємо
понад 400 підприємців, які приєднуються до нашого
продукту, без будь-яких
продавців у команді та лише одного менеджера служби підтримки.
ми також маємо великі цифри в наших
витратах на залучення клієнтів у нашому
життєвому значенні, тому вартість позиції клієнта
становить сімдесят доларів, вартість прямої трансляції
становить шістсот доларів, а наша валова
маржа становить 90 відсотків,
цього року ми також розмістили
косу риску вгорі, завдяки цьому ми в
зв’яжіться з великими фондами венчурного капіталу
в Сполучених Штатах, такими як general
Catalyst Lightspeed і Nia, і я
будемо дуже раді відповісти на будь-які запитання
і щиро дякую за вашу увагу, щиро
дякую за вашу презентацію,
а тепер розпочинається сесія Q a.  шановний,
пам’ятає, будь ласка, будь ласка, будь ласка, будь ласка,
і ми передамо вам
вперед,
пане Ендрю, будь ласка,
додайте будь-який слайд для інвестора,
е-е, я можу надіслати вам більше інформації,
дякую,
чудово, е-е, так, пане Вайсман, будь ласка,
це була чудова презентація, е-е,
що було вашим найуспішнішим засобом
залучення клієнтів, як у вас справи,
отже, е-е,
запитайте, залучайте наших користувачів або як
наші клієнти
так, е-е, по-перше, ми багато працюємо
з впливовими людьми, у нас є понад 17
фрілансерів у Сполучених Штатах і
Великобританії, тож е-е, вони  надайте нам
кілька відео про те, де
вони розповідають про свій досвід
використання zeli про свої результати тощо,
тоді ми беремо це відео та починаємо робити ставку на
рекламу на різних
каналах, і ми створюємо
якісь вірусні ефекти в різних
каналах  наприклад Tick Tock Facebook
Instagram, у нас є чудова спільнота з
понад десяти тисяч підприємців у
соціальних мережах, тому коли вони бачать нашу
рекламу в соціальних мережах і їм це
цікаво, вони натискають кнопку
нижче й переходять до нашої автоматизованої
суперавтоматизованої адаптації.  де ми ставимо їм
кілька запитань, і наприкінці цього
навчання вони додають дані своєї картки,
щоб розпочати пробний період, а також ми
надаємо їм повністю
готовий веб-магазин, створений за допомогою нашого
штучного інтелекту, тож настав
момент, коли  і вони почали
завдяки цьому своєму пробному періоду,
ще раз дуже дякую, це була чудова
робота, і мені подобається той факт, що ви так
орієнтуєтеся на показники,
дуже дякую, чи
можу я поставити запитання, вибачте,
так, у нас є пара  хвилин, тож
правильно, насправді я розробляв один
із цих ринків, тож питання,
гмм, ви коли-небудь думали створити
пошук у додатку чи у вас є такий,
ні, зараз його немає, але ми
думаємо про те, щоб підключити деякі речі
як це деякі такі інструменти, як цей, тому
що ми залучаємо все більше і
більше клієнтів із різних галузей,
тож я думаю, що це може
знадобитися нам через рік, так,
це як Marketplace, тож ви можете
створити програму, яка об’єднує  усі
ваші клієнти в одному, і якщо вам, якщо комусь із
ваших клієнтів просто потрібно зробити пошук,
велике спасибі за запитання,
дякую всім за активну
участь у сесії Q a, а тепер, ну,
ми погано в білому останнє, але
точно не менш важливе  стартап, е-е, на
сторінку, і
це буде стартове сканування, де я
з вами, дякую,
добре, звісно, ​​екран і гм,
привіт, мене звуть Кейт, я
співзасновник українських стартапів, можу
носити і е-е, галузь логістики зараз е-е
розвивається дуже швидко, і
з’являється багато захоплюючих стартапів, але все
ще є прогалина в ручній інвентаризації, яку
компанії повинні
надавати кожні півроку чи рік,
і
це деякі моменти про
проблему та те, як ми бачимо  рішення
тепер все автоматизовано, і наше
рішення – це послуга на основі дронів для
автоматизації збору даних,
тож як це відбувається зараз, це лише люди
зі сканерами, які збирають
інформацію, яку ми пропонуємо наступний дрон
літає над полицями, збирає візуальну
інформацію, після цього ми продовжуємо
разом шукати інформацію  і формує дійсно
дуже простий звіт для наших клієнтів,
який я продемонструю трохи пізніше, так, це
невелика
візуалізація про це та наші
переваги, тому ми орієнтовані на бізнес,
тому ми створюємо
процес, який не потребує  будь-які
витрати з боку компаній або будь-які
проблеми, е-е, для інтеграції з нами, щоб
усе було орієнтовано на бізнес, е-е,
ми використовуємо технологію, е-е, для того, щоб
забезпечити такий чудовий пристрій для
клієнтів, і це включає в себе машинне навчання
комп’ютерного бачення та нейронні мережі, щоб
забезпечити такі, як такі  рішення для наших
клієнтів, тож ми розробляємо програмне забезпечення,
яке працює на апаратному забезпеченні, але вже на
ринку,
ми працюємо з роздрібними торговцями
компаній MCG та компаніями електронної комерції, щоб
надавати такі послуги, а
також операторами 3pl,
тому ми маємо  спрогнозований
обсяг ринку на основі того, що ми можемо
отримати за три роки, а
також ми визначаємо наші географічні ринки, на
які ми орієнтуємося, ми вже створили
два проекти з
українськими компаніями в 2022 році і шукаємо
щоб продовжити його у 2023 році після
значного відновлення ринку
роздрібної торгівлі в Україні,
ми скануємо полиці та
стягуємо плату, де кожен випромінювач процесу
конкурентів, але це справді ранній
ринок, і зараз усі намагалися запропонувати
найкраще, і ми  використовуємо нашу власну
технологію, щоб не використовувати когось
іншого, тому без журналу постачальника чи чогось іншого,
і орієнтуємось на надання послуг, а не
просто на надання певного апаратного забезпечення
тощо,
я згадував про прогрес перед тим, як
почати, ми
спілкувалися з 25 компаніями в
Україні, щоб підтвердити, що це  справжня
проблема та отримали позитивні відгуки про те, що
так, вони хочуть її вирішити, у
нас є дорожня карта для того, щоб досягти
наших цілей і плануємо
рухатися вперед у цьому, е-е,
ми команда людей, які вже
сім років працюють
у сфері послуг на основі безпілотників і  ось чому
ми змогли виявити такий варіант використання
та зрозуміти, як задовольнити потреби клієнтів на поточному
етапі розвитку технологій у безпілотних літальних апаратах,
це деякі моменти, як ми
плануємо використати грант, тому що кожному
потрібне обладнання, яке працює  із спільним
рішенням тощо, а також створенням
візуальних матеріалів для веб-сайту, щоб пояснити, як
працює наша технологія та що це
безпечно для бізнесу та
працівників.
Я зупинюся на цьому, щиро дякую
за вашу увагу та готовий відповідати на
будь-які запитання,
дякую  вас за презентацію, і ми
вже маємо одну реакцію, пане,
порада, будь ласка,
це дуже гарна
презентація, дуже
спогадлива, дуже перспективна,
вам потрібно довести дві речі, принаймні
одну, що ваша точність краща,
ніж людська точність у  управління
складами, а по-друге, є
сильна рентабельність інвестицій і з двома клієнтами, яких
ви маєте на даний момент, що ви зробили,
щоб дізнатися про рентабельність інвестицій або про
точність своїх
складських операцій,
дякую за запитання  Я
повернусь до
слайдів один до одного, щоб пояснити точність, це
мене здивувало, тому що я думав, що
це дійсно вища, але згідно зі
статистикою через
помилки людського фактору, вибачте,
точні лише в 63 відсотках.  час,
так що він не такий високий, і у нас є два
джерела проблеми, одна
проблема з’являється деякий час,
сканування вручну, і це помилка людського фактору,
а друга така сама, але вона
з’являється, коли
працівник складу  на вантажівці доставляє коробку не
в правильне місце, і після цього
вони не мають можливості
швидко зрозуміти, де саме знаходиться коробка з
товаром,
тому я, сподіваюся, я відповім на перше
запитання, а на друге, що я мав
стурбований вашою точністю порівняно
зі звичайними складськими операціями.
96 відсотків
чудово, дякую, а потім про
рентабельність інвестицій.
їм не потрібно платити за
будь-яку інтеграцію, щоб платити лише за
послуги.
е-е, з платежами, які вони
повинні зробити для нас е-е, зараз ми
досліджуємо це, тому що у нас є два
проекти і один, щоб працювати більше, щоб
зрозуміти більше е-е, ви знаєте більше
цілей про це,
дякую,
дякую за запитання, у
нас є ще одне запитання  е-е, пане,
замініть підлогу,
добре, дякую за презентацію,
оскільки деякі ваші конкуренти використовують DJ
mavic
тощо, деякі стандартні
дрони, а я буду виробником апаратного забезпечення,
або ви просто зосередитеся на
управлінні даними тощо,
дякую вам за це  Питання.
Зараз я повертаюся до слайду. Ми
зосереджуємося на тому, щоб бути компанією з програмного забезпечення,
яка працює над іншим апаратним забезпеченням,
але ми також бачимо великий ризик того, що більшість
виробників «сухий готель», тому
це китайські виробники та Китай
компанії, і це тенденція, що
можуть бути деякі проблеми, пов’язані з
санкціями через китайські компанії,
тому ми розуміємо, як ми будемо
мати справу в разі
цієї ситуації,
тому ми не ви знаєте, ми
зосереджені на перегляді Providence, а не
просто на продажу апаратного забезпечення  чи щось таке, але у
нас є чітке бачення, як ми будемо ви
знати, як мати справу з такими, як ви знаєте, екстреними
ситуаціями чи щось у нас є
дорожня карта для створення апаратного рішення чи
цього якогось DJI достатньо для такого типу
трансмісії
мм-хм,
це нормально  і
якщо ви згадали якусь ситуацію, коли
оператори Warehouse
встановлюють книги з деякими продуктами не
неправильну форму або тип,
ну, це
сильно вирішує цю проблему,
він може
переміщатися по книгах і знаходить палицю, або
це не так вирішується на поточний
момент
зробив неправильно, має додаткові функції  ніж
звичайній людині, так, я бачу, тому для
роботи першого потрібно будь-яке обладнання,
наприклад, на голові п’ятого поверху
чи щось подібне, тож це певні
причини безпеки, або просто
це перший і другий
наша перша бізнес-модель полягає в тому, щоб
надати наглядачів, а друга
після певного етапу розробки
залишити як безпілотник для ну на
певному складі, і вони можуть літати над
ним, коли їм потрібно або коли виникне така
надзвичайна ситуація, наприклад, так
так, і вони можуть шукати в ньому набагато
більше, ти знаєш швидше, ніж
будь-хто, тому ми в
порядку, тому я просто міг би швидко знайти
книги, мені потрібно дати це сюди, навіть не
підтримувати, де я хочу так,
добре,
дякую  ви за презентацію
так, дякую за чудові запитання,
це був чудовий досвід, і
зрозуміти, які запитання ви можете з’явити,
і я, ну,
це був останній стартап, ми дякуємо всім
командам і суддям за їх важку роботу,
ну, ми всі робимо  чудова робота, я
заслуговую на перерву на каву, тож ми
зустрінемося через 15 хвилин,
і ми просимо вас залишитися в масштабі та
просто вимкнути камери та
мікрофони після короткої перерви, ми
повернемося з результатами наших
сьогоднішніх виступів,
тож будь ласка  усі, просто ввімкніть
мікрофони та відеокамери та випийте
гарної кави,
шановні учасники, шановний суддя, шановний,
усі учасники, які приєднуються до нас онлайн на
нашій трансляції на YouTube, ми
надаємо нашим суддям повну інформацію лише для того,
щоб дати відгук про стартапи
чи  щоб дати натхнення для їхніх
майбутніх персиків, тому, будь ласка, шановний суддя,
слово за вами,
хм, я вважав, що всі презентації
пропонують справжню цінність, і де я б
відзначив людей, які справді по-
справжньому продумали бізнес,
а не лише технологічний бік  отримав
від мене вищі оцінки, але
я чув, що не було жодного проекту, який не вартий того, щоб
продовжувати, е-е, і це особливо
неймовірно, враховуючи жахливу ситуацію, з
якою ви зараз стикаєтеся в Україні,
е-е, така креативність Інновація,
здається, що світ — це життя
якби я побачив
ці презентації, я б поняття не мав
про жахливу ситуацію, з якою ви
зіткнулися, тож ви знаєте, я знімаю перед вами капелюха. Я
думаю, що це чудовий ранок, я
багато чого навчився, і деякі з презентацій  Я
б протистояв найкращим у
світі, але так само добре, як будь-яка
презентація в Каліфорнії, Нью-Йорку
, Мюнхені чи Лондоні, тож тим, хто
був у вищому рейтингу, вітаю, але
всі продовжуйте, тому що це
всі ідеї, які варто реалізовувати, дякую  ви за те, що
запросили нас приєднатися,
містере Вайзмен, велике вам спасибі, що приєдналися до
нас сьогодні і за те, що ви є другом
України, е-е, ми цінуємо вашу
карму сьогодні, Велика Британія була останнім місцем, яке я
відвідав до того, як почався COVID, тому о,
хотів би приїхати  назад
так, ми сподіваємось, що скоро знову побачимося,
найголовніше, будьте в безпеці,
так, велике спасибі, дякую,
а тепер ми запрошуємо ну, Оксану,
до чотирьох, ну, з відгуками, ну,
для наших стартапів,
дякую, Марія, я хочу сказати спасибі
всім стартапам  пам’ятайте, що ви
всі переможці, ви чудові люди,
які створюють інноваційні рішення
в такий складний для нас час, тому ви
чудові всі, дякую вам за вашу
презентацію та навчання сьогодні, і я
бажаю вам усім успіхів у пошуку
ваших інвесторів, е-е  виграти в цей
день виступів і отримати певну фінансову підтримку від
наших партнерів, а також мати
можливість у майбутньому розвивати
свою бізнес-ідею,
дякую всім,
дякую, що ви з нами та за ваші
відгуки, а ні, ми в білому,
Андреа Галлі, ну на  четвертий, е-е, із
відгуками про наших стартапів, е-е,
будь ласка, слово за вами, добре, дякую,
е-е, за презентації, і
там було кілька досить цікавих
презентацій з класними цифрами, і я
бажаю ще одного проекту, щоб не забувати
про інвесторів, щоб зробити кілька  слайди, і
це вказує на те, що ви навіть не
піднімаєтеся, і на поточний момент деякі
гроші ви повинні розуміти
майбутнє Дорожня
карта для вашого проекту і
хм, звичайно, ми не повинні забувати, що
хм, головна причина, чому клієнти вибирають вас,
безпечні  час і гроші або заробляти більше
грошей, тож принаймні вам слід
продемонструвати загальне порівняння з вашими
конкурентами, щоб зрозуміти,
для чого ваше рішення та як воно
робить кнопку прокрутки, принаймні, щоб
заощадити час,
але щоб бути хорошим бізнесом у  у майбутньому вам
варто поговорити про гроші чи про
перевірку маркетингових бюджетів е-е-е-е-е-е.
дякую за все, це було дуже
цікаво,
дякую, що приєдналися до нас і
були таким учасником активності, якщо хтось
із видатних суддів захоче поділитися
своїми результатами, будь ласка,
слово відкрите,
а якщо не без очікування, ми
раді поділитися  підсумки нашого сьогоднішнього
виступу,
і ми почнемо з енергетичної та
екологічної сфери
перші е-
е, перші стартапи, які отримають
фінансову підтримку це
maxar LLC
optisan E-Waste recycling
solar plaques mouth water Club waist to
Green hydrogen energy recover and vitrog
please Europe house  і
ми більш ніж впевнені, що ця підтримка
дасть вам правильну основу для розвитку
та створення справжніх єдинорогів, а також для
подальшого розвитку інфраструктури та
галузевих результатів.
Введення програмного забезпечення для
сканування м’яких кутів Цегла Lego Echo.
Переробка природного каменю.
Відходи шламу та запуск.  грінго,
ми отримаємо підтримку, так що, шановні
учасники, шановні судді, всі, хто
відвідає нас сьогодні, ми запрошуємо вас
підписатися на наші офіційні ресурси,
канал у телеграмі, наш
канал на YouTube, наш Facebook і всі
соціальні мережі, якими ми будемо ділитися все більше і
більше  ну інформація про
можливості української
екосистеми стартапів та результати
розвитку та успіху успіх наших
стартапів ну так дякуємо, що ви з
нами і чекаємо вас на наших подальших
заходах дякую
всім
гарного вечора дякую дякую дякую
всім хлопці
дякую, чудового дня, чудового
дня, хлопці,
дякую
іноземні